monsieur le Président Madame la
Directrice générale nous avons jugé
utile de vous entendre à nouveau afin
d'aborder les sujets que nous n'avons
pas eu le temps d'aborder le 2 novembre
et de clarifier les éléments qui nous
semblaient mériter un examen plus
approfondi à la suite des réponses
parfois imprécises pour ne pas dire
inexactes que vous avez faite madame la
rapporteur s'est rendu dans vos locaux
vendredi dernier afin de se faire
communiquer un certain nombre de
documents le 4 novembre vous avez par
ailleurs de votre côté adressé à la
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale un
courrier dont la presse s'est fait écho
dans lequel vous estimez que votre
audition s'est déroulée dans les
conditions indignes de l'institution sur
le plan de la forme et déloyal sur le
fond faut-il rappeler que nous sommes
tous ici attachés à la vitalité du monde
sportif et à ce que le sport a
d'essentiels à apportter à notre société
cependant l'objet de nos travaux est
d'identifier pour mieux les corriger un
certain nombre de dysfonctionnement et
dériv
inacceptables c'est dans cette
perspective que nous cherchons à
comprendre si les règles procédural ont
bien été respectés dans le traitement
disciplinaire de plusieurs affaires qui
ont été porté à notre connaissance au
sein de la fédération que vous
présidez c'est ce que nous avons fait
avec l'ensemble des représentants de
fédération que nous avons entendu dans
le courrier adressé à la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale
dont vous avez adressé une copie au
président de la République vous indiquez
je vous cite en vertu du principe de
séparation des pouvoirs nous ne pouvons
tolérer le fait que les députés puissent
ouvertement remettre en cause les
décisions prises par les organes
disciplinaires indépendants
permettez-moi monsieur le Président de
vous rappeler que les commissions
d'enquête sont parfaitement fondé à
s'interroger sur le fonctionnement de
l'action disciplinaire des fédérations
dont nos travaux ont déjà permis de
pointer de nombreuses
défaillances on peut en revanche
s'interroger sur la conception de la
séparation des pouvoirs d'un président
de fédération qui se retourne vers le
président de la République pour
critiquer le mode de fonctionnement
d'une commission d'enquête parlementaire
ces précisions étant fait vous avez
affirmé lors de votre audition du 2
octobre devant cette commission
d'enquête que vous avez effectué un
signalement au procureur de la
République au titre de l'article 40 du
code de la procédure pénale au sujet de
l'affaire claire Palou pouvez-vous nous
reconfirmer que vous avez effectué un
signalement au procureur en application
de l'article 40 du code de procédure
pénale cette audition est ouverte à la
presse et elle est retransmise en direct
sur le site de l'Assemblée nationale
avant de vous laisser la parole et
d'entamer nos échanges je vous rappelle
que l'article 6 de l'ordonnance du 17
novembre 1958 relative au fonctionnement
des assemblées parlementaires impose aux
personnes entendu par une commission
d'enquête de prêter serment de dire la
vérité toute la vérité rien que la
vérité je vous invite donc chacun votre
tour à dire je le jure après avoir
activé votre micro mais je sais que vous
connaissez le fonctionnement du micro je
J
merci donc vous avez la
parole je répondrai à votre question
concernant l'article 40 tout à l'heure
je voudrais si vous me le permettez
faire un petit propos pr liiminaire
assez breve d'ailleurs euh pour rappeler
un petit peu dans quelles conditions euh
nous venons à cette deuxè audition c'est
la seconde fois donc que je m'adresse à
vous au nom de la Fédération française
d'athlétisme et je vais m'efforcer
d'être bref dans ce propos
introductif je tiens tout d'abord à vous
dire que si j'ai pu regretter la forme
de nos
échanges il n'y a aucune défiance de la
part de notre fédération envers votre
commission bien au contraire nous nous
soumettons volontiers à votre examen je
souhaite plutôt vous faire part de ce
que nous avons retenu dans notre
première audition nous souhaitons comme
vous avancer les luttes contre les
violences sont est un sujet difficile
complexe qui est présent dans toutes les
sphère de notre société hélas et le
sport concentre beaucoup de violences
elles sont d'ailleurs de plusieurs
natures physique psychologique sexiste
et sexuel et elles sont présentes dans
le sport de très haut niveau comme dans
la pratique quotidiennes notamment celle
des jeunes et dans de nombreuses
disciplines
oui nous devons protéger nos licenciers
nous le savons nous le faisons et nous
devons encore progresser
collectivement toutefois parce que le
sujet est sérieux et grave nous n
pouvions laisser dire sans réagir que la
FA n'agit pas de manière
transparente tous les PV tous les
procèsverbaux de nos commissions sont
d'ailleurs consultables sur notre site
internet je l'affirme à nouveau la FFA
n'a rien à caché et ne protège aucun
athlète ni aucun entraîneur parce qu'il
serait potentiellement médaillable en
vue des Giau de Paris ce n'est pas le
cas les Jeux olympiques et paralympiques
de Paris 2024 événement exceptionnel que
nous attendons depuis un siècle
constitue autant une opportunité qu'une
forme de difficulté pour nos fédération
cela crée beaucoup d'attentes et de
frustration et nous devons les gérer
quotidiennement comme cela a été dit par
d'autres présidents de fédération que
vous avez auditionné nous avons des
moyens limités y compris de d'un point
de vue disciplinaire au regard de notre
responsabilité la Fédération via son
organ disciplinaire qui est indépendant
effectu un travail sérieux je l'ai déjà
affirmé ici et je pense que vous avez pu
le constater par vous-même à travers les
pièces que nous avons transmises la
semaine dernière vous nous interrogez
sur les fonctionnement de nos
organisations dans les luttes contre les
violences moi je parlerai plutôt des
limites du cadre légal actuel dans
lequel évolue l'ensemble des acteurs ce
n'est pas assez efficient et ça ne nous
permet pas une bonne coordination et
diffusion des informations entre nos
services en écoutant à nouveau les
témoignages de Claire Palou et Emma udou
je me rends bien compte de leur
perception de comment elles ont ressenti
tout cela le déc age entre nos
perceptions est immense et c'est pour
cela que nous devons retenir et c'est ce
quoi nous et c'est sur quoi nous devons
vraiment progresser pour conclure nous
partageons tous des valeurs communes que
vous avez rappelé puisque nous nous
engageons tous au service de l'intérêt
général et c'est pour cela que je
souhaite que cette audition puisse se
dérouler dans un respect mutuel à la
hauteur des enjeux liés au sujet dont
traite votre commission je je vous
remercie pour votre
écoute monsieur le Président je voudrais
juste vous rappeler que bien sûr que
nous ne sommes pas là au tribunal c'est
pas en aucun cas nous sommes juste là et
c'est pour ça qu'on a souhaité vous
auditionner une deuxième fois pour
échanger ensemble et juste dans un but
bien sûr de faire progresser ce
mouvement sportif dans tous les
dysfonctionnements qu'on peut constater
qu'on peut montrer du doigt et sur
lequel chaque fédération bien sûr chaque
Pr président à l'occasion de s'exprimer
avec nous et donc nous sommes de bonne
fois pour travailler ensemble il faut
bien l'entendre comme ça aussi je l'ai
bien entendu et j'ai bien analysé
justement en en écoutant vos vos
auditions d'autres collègues que on
travaille tous dans l'intérêt général et
et c'est vrai que nous sommes toujours
disons à l'écoute des victimes alors
pour en revenir à votre question sur
l'article 40 euh dans cette première
audition qui a tourné autour de deux cas
seulement je me rappelle alors peut-être
que je me suis mal exprimé mais j'avais
l'impression qu'on était ce joursl dans
un dialogue de Sour excusez-moi mais on
se comprenait pas alors je dis pas que
j'ai peut-être mal compris moi-même et
peut-être vous aussi je sais pas on
n'est pas là pour dire qui a compris qui
a mal compris mais je suis pas habilité
moi à déclencher un article 40 article
40 c'est mon DTN qui qui le déclenche et
dans le cas de l'affaire Palou dans le
cas de l'affaire Palou effectivement
comme cette affaire s'était passée
s'était déroulée dans les locaux de
l'INS notre DTN et le directeur de
l'INSEP se sont mis d'accord et c'est
l'INSEP qui a déclaré l'article 40 c'est
pas les deux personnes en même temps il
y a eu un accord entre le DTN et un
accord avec le directeur de l'inscep
d'autre part je le rappelle une dernière
fois dans l'affaire Palou et nous avons
un mail que vous avez peut-être dans
lequel elle nous remercie claire Palou
elle remercie les services de la
Fédération parce que c'est nous qui
l'avons guidé dans ces démarches elle a
déposé une une main courante ou une
plainte en
gendarmerie voilà c'est voilà comment
l'affaire a démarré l'affaire cler Palou
a démarré avec ces aspects-là voilà mais
c'est pas moi qui a déclarché la
l'article 40 je ne suis pas habilité à
le faire alors la ministre des Sports a
rappelé en audition que les présidents
de la Fédération des fédérations étaient
assimilés à des agents publics pour
l'article 40 donc à juste titre vous
pouvez déclencher un article 40 dans la
mesure où les fédérations sont
délégateur je vous remercie de la
précision je le savais
pas alors merci à
vous écoutez moi je vais tenter de vous
poser quelques questions même si comme
vous l'avez fait remarquer peut-être
involontairement par mail nous ne sommes
que des députés arrogants et
incompétents mais je pense que nous
pourrons au moins essayer d'avancer sur
quelques sujets ensemble puisque vous
avez indiqué que nous na'avions
l'occasion de traiter que deux cas il en
reste plusieurs autres effectivement sur
lesqueles on aurait aimé échanger avec
vous je c'est bien parce que vous voyez
cette deème audition permet aussi à
chacun d'apprendre y compris sur la la
question de l'article 40 et le fait
qu'un président de fédération est tout à
fait habilité
à le faire donc vous nous avvez indiqué
effectuer des signalements au procureur
dans tous les cas pouvez-vous repréciser
dans quel cas vous effectuez des
articles 40 et si dans les 35 cas de VSS
que vous nous avez transmis la dernière
fois un article 40 a été effectué
systématiquement pour je je reprends ce
que j'ai dit la dernière audition
lorsque un cas nous est signalé et on en
a eu 35 là sur les trois ou quatre
dernières années d'ailleurs on peut vous
donner le nombre par année je suis saisi
soit par le comité d'éthique soit par le
service juridique et en fonction en
fonction donc de la
gravité disons des faits qui me sont
communiqués je demande à la Commission
de discipline de la Fédération de se
saisir de ce
dossier moi je n'ai jamais signaler je
vous l'ai dit d'abord parce que
j'ignorais que j'avais le droit de le
faire je n'ai jamais saisi l'article 40
direct directement par contre comme je
vous l'ai dit la dernière fois nous nous
sommes renforcés et c'est normal pour
traiter tous ces cas on a un service
juridique professionnel et compétent qui
ensuite instruit instruit directement
l'affaire voilà et pour rester pour
laisser ce service cette commission
disciplinaire disons travailler
sereinement dans le droit administratif
je n'ai pas de communication je n'ai pas
de communication sur la façon dont est
organisée l'audition des différents
témoins des différents responsables ce
ce dont j'ai connaissance et que je vous
ai transmis c'est le résultat de la
commission de discipline et de la
commission d'appel voilà moi je
n'interviens pas disons la B la seule
d'ailleurs vous l'avez vu dans le
tableau que je vous ai fourni les
signalements c'est moi qui les ai fait à
la commission de
discipline voilà merci peut-être juste
pour préciser euh comment vous évaluez
la gravité en fait d'un signalement
est-ce que il y a des paramètres ou des
indicateurs enfin comment vous évaluer
qu'il faut que la Commission se saisisse
d'un dossier parce que vous nous avez
dit en fonction de la gravité donc mais
sur quel sur la base de quel critère
vous évaluer ça déjà alors en ce qui
concerne les incivilités hein si vous
voulez je vous remettrai aussi les 118
cas avec le si vous voulez les les les
différents cas que le comité d'éthique
euh disons traite d'abord dans un
premier temps hein avant d'aller en
commission de discipline il y a le
comité d'éthique qui vait arriver à un
certain nombre de cas et qui nous les
transmet bon donc tout ce qui concerne
les violences sexuelles tout est allé en
commission de discipline voilà sur ces
cas-là pour moi ce sont des cas graves y
compris d'ailleurs les deux cas que nous
avons évoqué la dernière fois il y a eu
immédiatement saisie de la
conditionition de discipline ensuite je
peux vous dire
si ça vous intéresse alors attendez je
vais le retrouver la commission
d'éthique voilà je peux vous dire mais
je vous donnerai le document depuis 2017
la commission d'éthique et de
déontologie hein a traité 118 affaires
sur les 118 affaires 40 47 cas 40 %
concernne la diffamation la
discrimination le
dénigrement 18 % concerne les affaires à
connotation sexuelles ou sexiste pour
celle-là c'est les fameuses 35 là tout
est allé en commission de discipline 8 %
concern le harcèlement moral 2 % les
atteintes à la laïcité 11 % ont été
transférés à un organisme disciplinaire
de première instance et 10 % ont eu en
prolongement juridique ça veut dire que
le comité d'éthique ensuite nous éclaire
un comité d'éthique qui a été créé je
vous l'ai dit en 2013 qui fonctionne
déjà bien avant qu'il soit so rendu
obligatoire et nous transmet après ses
conclusions voyez quand il s'agit par
exemple d'un cas d'harcèlement moral
hein on on évalue après l'étude du
comité d'éthique si ça nécessite une
commission de discipline ou un rappel à
l'ordre mais pour les je je répète que
pour les cas de d'atentees sexuel et de
dérives sexuelles ou sexistes chaque
fois les 35 ans ont été euh traité par
le conseil de discipline par le comité
de discipline
pardon alors peut-être pour revenir
justement puisque vous évoquez les deux
affaires qu'on a dont on a beaucoup
parlé la dernière fois sur l'affaire
Palou nous vous avions interrogé sur la
procédure qui a été suivie euh au moment
du traitement de cette affaire et nous
souhaitions savoir si la procédure
suivie était la procédure prévue et
formalisé mais euh enfin la dernière
fois vous ne connaissiez pas la la
procédure dans son ensemble est-ce que
vous vous avez pu vérifier depuis si la
procédure qui a été suivé est conforme
aux règles que se fixe la FF1
oui nous avons contrôlé justement suite
à cette première audition et d'ailleurs
vous avez tous les documents qui vous
ont été fournis euh je pense que dans
l'affaire Palou il y a un dossier qui
fait plus de 150 pages donc tout ça ça a
été instruit mais comme je vous l'ai dit
et comme je le répète je me suis je n'ai
pas le droit à partir du moment le
commission pendante d'intervenir et donc
moi on ne me donne que les conclusions
après c'est au juriste à conduire et au
président de la Commission à conduire
non pas son enquête mais ses ses
auditions comme il entend voilà c'est
tout je je n'ai pas si vous voulez dans
notre fonctionnement actuel dans notre
fonctionnement actuel tel qu'il est
aujourd'hui et s'il devait évoluer on
est prêt à le faire évoluer mais en
droit administratif c'est ce que nous
avons fait
voilà madame Reed là-dessus parce que
moi j'avais on avait on avait une
interrogation sur vous savez cette
fameuse convocation à 24h la veille et
la manière dont elle avait été rédigée
peut-être que depuis vous avez plus
d'informations
là-dessus alors elle avait eu une
convocation avant vous avez fait
parvenir en fait l'ensemble de la
chronologie des échanges avec Madame
Palou ensuite la l'incompréhension que
j'avais exprimé comme un un K prococo
c'est qu'en fait elle est convoquée en
tant que témoin et pas en tant que que
victime donc non accompagné cétait ça le
sujet en fait enfit l'incompréhension
qu'on a eu toutes les deux lorsque
Madame la rapporteuse vous m'avez
exprimé la problématique qu'elle soit
enfin en tout cas que vous estimez qu'
il était nécessaire qu'elle soit
accompagné
alors accompagné euh oui il y avait une
incompréension là-dessus mais aussi le
fait que euh l'auteur présumé puisse
rebondir sur sur ses propos et donc
qu'il aurait été présent au moment où
elle était entendue donc est-ce que vous
avez pu avoir des éléments plus précis
là-dessus parce que je crois que
normalement vous ne faites pas de
confrontation non il y avait pas de
confrontation en fait encore une fois
comme le disait le président tout à
l'heure le président de la commission
organise ses auditions comme il le
souhaite on peut pas nous entrer en dans
son organisation en revanche on
demande aux témoins présumer victime
présumer agresseur d'être là le même
jour ils se croisent pas et et ils ne
sont pas ensemble à à à comment dire à
exprimer des
choses sachant que sur cette affaire on
savait que la le présid coupable était
en
visio merci
euh je pense que incompréhension mais
après on a eu l'occasion d'en échanger
au moment de la visite du contrôle sur
pièce vient de la manière dont le mail a
été rédigé qui laisse supposer qui
laisse penser en tout cas qu'elle se que
la victime se serait retrouvé face à à à
à l'auteur présumé des faits donc
peut-être aussi une réflexion à avoir
sur les modalités
de c'est effectivement les premiers
enseignements qu'on qu'on peut avoir qu'
a eu il y a sans doute à chaque fois
lorsque on envoie ce ce type de mail
d'une relation qui est froide qui est
pas
forcément dans dans dans dans enfin
empathique hein donc c'est des juristes
pas du tout non c'est des dossiers qui
sont juridic administrative donc
forcément il faut qu'on
s'interroge sur comment on accompagne
ensuite après ce type de convocation euh
les athlètes qui euh qui sont en
commission
discipline
vous permettez je excusez-moi je
voudrais rajouter par rapport à la
directrice général que nous avons pris
conscience justement que ce qui proco va
nous amener aujourd'hui à travailler
peut-être un peu différemment dans la
forme avec nos juristes qui sont des
professionnels et qui ont des termes
juridiques qui peuvent effectivement
dans des moments difficiles vécus par
les présumés victimes qui peuvent sentir
ça comme quelque chose de froid et de
moins impathique donc effectivement on
va faire des efforts là-dessus on va
demander à nos juristes de faire des
efforts dans la rédaction parce que
comme l'a dit la directrice générale
céit pas une confrontation claire Palou
était invité comme témoin c'était pas
elle qui était convoqué en commission de
discipline c'était vraiment le présumé
coupable voilà et donc il y a eu cette
confusion effectivement on convient que
les termes juridiques parfois sontun peu
froid et ça peut
choquer depuis quand la fédération à la
Fédération disposez-vous d'un d'un
référent intégrité d'un référent
violence sexuelle et d'un référent
honorabilité s'il vous
plaît de
mémoire je pense que ça doit dater de
2020 2019- 2020 peut-être même un peu
avant hein euh nous sommes toujours mis
en conformité avec les demandes du
ministère et nous avons effectivement un
référent honorabilité parmi les élus et
parmi la la DTN parmi les techniciens du
ministère nous avons un référent donc
honorabilité on a on avait constitué une
cellule d'intégrité avec le comité
d'éthique parce que le fait peut-être
d'avoir été en avance par rapport à
d'autres fédérations nous nous avveit
permis de mettre en place ce comité
d'éthique qui fonctionne depuis 2013 et
qui avait pris ses habitudes donc dans
les
nouvelles dispositions qui nous sont
imposées par l'État aujourd'hui on a un
un représentant des élus et un
représentant de la DTN qui suivent ces
dossiers qui suivent les
commissions donc vous mentionnez donc
l'année 20 or le contrat de délégation
indique que votre stratégie en matière
de lutte contre les violences repose
principalement sur votre engagement à
désigner ces référents trois des tris
des 6 tir traduisent des actions
concrètes dans ce titre de contrat que
signifie-t-il donc que vous vous êtes
engagé à mettre en œuvre des
dispositif déjà en
place j'ai pas compris votre question
excusez-moi vous vous engagez à mettre
des dispositifs qui sont déjà mis en
place précédemment si je comprends bien
voilà si vous voulez on a on a essayé
dans notre contexte c'est mon
prédécesseur qui avait créé la
commission d'éthique en 2013 on a été la
première fédération à constituer une
commission d'éthique qui a d'ailleurs
travailler depuis sur de nombreux
dossiers plus particulièrement à
l'époque comme la parole était pas
libérée c'était c'est plus des dossiers
sur les incivilités vous savez les les
conflits qu'on peut avoir sur le terrain
voilàin donc et des conflits de de
personnes et de dirigeants mais lorsque
nous avons été amenés par le ministère
dans le cont de délégation à mettre en
place nous avons suivi des
recommandations et nous avons adapté le
fonctionnement de notre comité d'éthique
en relation avec une personne élue comme
je dis et une personne de la DTN voilà
donc c'est ça ça c'est vrai que c'est
quand vous avez des habitudes c'est
difficile de les changer et ça a créé
d'ailleurs quelques conflits
interpersonnels dans la cellule
d'intégrité il y a eu quelques confit de
personnes à l'intérieur de la fédération
qui ne parlent pas le même langage c'est
vérité peut-être juste là-dessus ce qui
nous a semblé en fait qui nous a
peut-être étonné c'est que vous signez
le contrat de délégation en mars 2022 et
dans ce contrat de délégation dans les
objectifs sur la lutte contre les VSS en
fait la moitié des points sont déjà R is
alors que normalement c'est censé être
un contrat d'objectif justement pour la
lutte contre les VSS donc si on y met
déjà des choses qui sont déjà réalisées
si vous voulez ça veut dire vous avez
déjà fait 50 % des choses avant même la
signature de votre contrat de délégation
c'est pour ça en fait en terme de
nouveaux dispositifs euh c'est ça qui
nous intéresse aujourd'hui c'est quels
sont les nouveaux dispositifs dont la
fédération se dote ou va se doter pour
avancer sur cette question sur les
sujets déjà réalisés c'est des sujets en
fait qu'on réalise tous les ansin par
exemple lorsque on souscrit à une
licence d'athlétisme euh chacun doit
lire la charte éthique et déontologie
euh et donc ça c'est des choses que
finalement on remet à chaque année dans
le contrat de de de délégation j'imagine
que ça doit être ce ce de ça il
s'agit la par exemple la désignation du
référent intégrité du référent violence
sexuelle d'un référent honorabilité tout
ça était déjà mis en place par la FFA et
en fait vous l'avez remis dans le
contrat délégation donc on peut pas
considérer que ce soit une nouvelle un
nouveau dispositif de lutte contre les
violences parce que c'est quelque chose
qui était déjà existant en fait c'est ça
c'est veut dire que un moment et
d'ailleurs la directrice des Sports nous
avait dit que les contrats avaient été
rédigés à la vavite parce que tout le
monde était pressé à ce moment-là mais
ça nous questionne sur justement quels
objectifs et enfin quel et quels outils
vous vous vous vous souhaitez vous
dotter pour lutter contre les violences
qui ne sont pas déjà inscrits dans ce
contrat de délégation qui semble avoir
été é écrit rapidement pour justement
lutter contre ce fléo je vais vous
répondre oui effectivement on a on a
créé on est une des fédérations avec
avoir créé notre propre office de
formation à tous les domaines et
aujourd'hui dans toutes les formations
que nous dispensons le premier module
avant de poursuivre que ce soit une
formation de juges d'entraîneurs de
dirigeants le premier module c'est le
module de l'éthique et ça existe bien
avant
2022 ça veut dire que si demain vous
décidez de vous impliquer dans un club
d'athlétisme et de devenir dirigeante
vous allez être amené à vous faire une
formation de dirigeant le premier module
que vous allez retrouver c'est
l'éthique et les licenciés depuis
plusieurs années pour valider la licence
d'ailleurs ça nous pose quelques
problèmes parce que pour les mineurs
c'est souvent les parents qui le font
vous voyez et ça prend du retard euh ils
sont obligés de passer par le le com par
le par la charte éthique tant qu'ils
n'ont pas tant qu'ils n'ont pas certifié
qu'ils avaient lu la charte éthique la
licence n'est pas validé voilà donc ce
sont des des effectivement des
dispositifs qu'on avait déjà mis avant
2022 peut-être juste pour préciser aussi
un peu les choses ce qui nous interroge
nous on entend que vous avez mis en
place le dispositif avant c'est si vous
voulez le cet outil de contrat de
délégation qui est censé justement être
un document ambitieux signé entre l'État
et les fédérations pour avancer sur des
questions et notamment sur la question
des la lutte contre les violences et en
tant que tel cet outil s'il ne fait que
lister ce qui est déjà mis en place par
les fédérations ça nous semble enfin
voilà comme outil en terme de délégation
ça nous semble peu ambitieux y compris
d'ailleurs en matière d'évaluation
comment on évalue à la fin de ce contrat
de délégation des choses qui au moment
de sa signature était déjà réalisé c'est
c'est plus l'outil en tant que tel qui
nous interroge que les actions que vous
avez mise en place en
amont pour pour essayer justement de
rentrer dans dans les clous justement je
l'IS préparé nous avons un plan de
prévention des violences qui est que
nous sommes en train de mettre en place
aujourd'hui avec le directeur technique
national avec la directrice des sports
on lui a communiqué d'ailleurs on a été
reçu entre les les deux auditions par la
directrice des sports pour initier
d'autres partenariats en plus de celui
de colosse on a l'intention d'initier
notre partenariat de mieux communiquer
et de lancer une campagne
d'information avec justement plus de
formation auprès des ligues et auprès
des référents de ligue de communiquer
sur nos dossiersfin sur nos nos médias
fédéraux atlac réseaux sociaux la
nouvelle charte d'éthique que nous avons
retravaillé avec un guide pratique et
nous soumettrons l'obtention des labels
à la formation des dirigeants et des
entraîneur donc on va faciliter aussi le
le processus de signalement hein on a
fait notre propre euh site là-dessus
hein notre propre adresse mail pour le
signalement et l'idée euh qui a commencé
d'ailleurs c'est d'organiser des
webinaires avec les personnes qui sont
responsables du service juridique et
avec le comité d'éthique et de
déontologie pour sensibiliser dans un
premier temps tous les cts et tous les
entraîneurs voilà nous c'est un plan de
prévention que nous avons mis en place
et que nous essayons maintenant
effectivement de d'adapter à ce qui
existait
avant peut-être justement dans le
contrat de délégation la Fédération
mentionne la valorisation d'un système
de signalement des violences incivilité
et discrimination de toute nature et de
la formalisation d'une procédure de
traitement de ces signalements peut-être
si vous pouvez nous expliquer en quoi
consiste ce système et lors du contrôle
sur place il nous avait ind il nous
avait été indiqué qu'une adresse mail
dédiée avait été créée à cette fin en
fait on a cherché sur le site internet
on l'a pas trouvé donc peut-être vous
pouvez nous dire où se situe C adresse
mail alors moi ce que je peux vous dire
effectivement on a peut-être
certainement des lacunes sur la
diffusion avec le site internet qu'on
est en train de recomposer d'ailleurs
mais cette adresse signalement a été
créée et elle a été communiquée aux
entraîneurs et elle a été communiquée au
cts voilà
alors peut-être effectivement on doit
faire un effort maintenant sur la
communication on a une prochaine revue
fédérale qui sur quelques jours et je
pense que on aura un beaucoup de travail
à faire pour la faire
connaître vous indiqué donc ça a été
transmis aux entraîneurs au cts mais
pour les licenciés c'estàd qu'une
victime par exemple qui voudrait se
saisir cette adresse mail où est-ce
qu'elle peut trouver cette
adresse on est en train on a créé
d'ailleurs ce qu'on pourrait appelé
notre article 40 qui fait partie
d'ailleurs de la du code éthique et qui
que normalement tous les licencier
doivent lire et là si vous voulez vous
faites je vous invite à aller sur le
site voir comment vous vous licenciez si
vous avez envie de prendre une licence à
un moment vous tombez là-dessus hein et
à partir de là et bien à partir de là il
est indiqué que tous les licenciés
doivent nous signaler toute dérivve ou
toute forme de violence qui constaterai
voilà alors c'est pas encore si vous
voulez on n pas été suffisamment
communiquant sur ce dossier j'en
convient mais ça figure effectivement
dans notre code éthique al c'est pas
enfin j'appelle le notre article 40 on
l'a pas appelé article 40 c'est c'est
l'équivalent de l'article 40 voilà pour
les
licenciés sur le site Internet de la
Fédération elle doit se trouver c'est un
site qui est un peu complexe chez nous
on est en train de retravailler sur
toute la refonte du site pour euh
septembre 2024 enfin on va essayer de
d'avoir un un nouveau site en premier
trimestre mais l'idée c'est que il soit
prêt pour la rentrée des des clubs 2024
euh mais dans information athlète il me
enfin club licencier euh il me semble
qu'elle est là mais euh je peux pas le
préciser est-ce que euh suite à ces
justement à ces petits ajustements
est-ce que vous avez eu des retours du
ministère des Sports là-dessus est- que
par exemple madame Bourdet vous a
signalé bah comme nous on a fait là sur
la le l'adresse qui n'est pas qui n'est
pas visible sur le site internet sur les
modalités de signalement est-ce que vous
avez eu des retours sur cela alors moi
j'ai participé avec la directrice
générale avec le DTN c'était le 6 avril
le oui c'est oui le 6 avril he c'est
bien ça ça va tellement vite à une
réunion justement pour l'évaluation de
notre contrat de délégation et sur ce
sujet-là je maintiens d'ailleurs ce que
je vous avais dit la première fois on a
été félicité par rapport au signalement
et par rapport à ce que nous
communiquons au service des sport à la
direction des sport on n' pas eu de
remarque si vous voulez de la part de la
direction des sport sur cette partie-là
on a eu des remarques sur le le suivi
médical on a eu des remarques sur
certains sujet où on est en retard mais
sur ce sujet-là on n pas eu de de
remarque alors peut-être justement sur
la question du suivi médical euh
pareil on a eu
l'occasion de regarder le tableau donc
que vous avez rempli pour le ministère
des Sports et donc vous vous indiquer
que qu'il y a 100 % de réalisation de
suivi enfin que c'est atteint alors que
justement nous avz une information
différentes euh est-ce que vous pouvez
nous préciser justement vous venez de
nous indiquer que le 6 avril on vous
avait indiqué justement qu'il y avait un
retard donc depuis ça veut dire que
depuis le 6 avril vous avez atteint
l'objectif sur le suivi médicalisé
non alors si vous voulez le suivi
médical réglementaire auquel sont soumis
les athlète on avait un retard
considérable ces dernières années on a
on nous a dit qu'on avait
progressé ce ce tableau est rempli
d'ailleurs par la DTN et pas par
nous-même he par le par la commission
médicale et par la DTN nous avons un
médecin qui suit régulièrement et qui
relance ce qui se passe c'est que dans
ce suivi médical il y a plusieurs
contrôles et que souvent souvent
quelques athlètes ne vont pas au bout
des contrôles par exemple ils font tout
le suivi cardiaque et puis ils oublient
de faire le suivi pour le le pour pour
le dentare par exemple vous voyez donc
il y a beaucoup de dossiers qui étaient
incomplets ce qui nous a été dit ce
jour-là ce qui nous a été dit ce jour-là
c'est que nous avions je retiens le
chiffr à peu près com a dit je l'ai pas
en mémoire hein 75 % des athlètes qui
étaient à jour plus là d'ailleurs tu do
l' voir et que il y avait encore un
effort à faire pour à peu près un quart
des athlètes qui ne sont pas en
situation
régulière j'ai juste pas compris madame
la rapporteur parce que le chiffre on
l'a donné effectivement précisément et
comme j'ai j'ai pu participer à cette
réunion je l'ai mais j'aimerais bien
avoir effectivement la la la question
précise alors peut-être pour vous
préciser les choses c'est que sur le
tableau qui nous a été remis justement
par la DTN de la FFA sur la question du
de la surveillance médicale
réglementaire en fait il y a juste écrit
attends comme objectif et et en fait
c'est bon alors je comprends que c'est
une
autoévaluation donc ça déjà ça nous
questionne parce que y compris sur les
indicateurs visiblement c'est la DTN ou
la Fédération elle-même qui choisit les
indicateurs sur lesquels elle décide de
s'évaluer donc là on est interrogatif
aussi sur bah en fait on peut pas être
jugé parti donc si on décide nous-même
des indicateurs
c'est plus facile de choisir des
indicateurs qui nous sont plus
favorables je dis pas que c'est le cas
mais voilà puis là d'ailleurs il y a pas
d'indicateur qui qui est préciser il y a
juste écrit attend voilà après sur la
réalisation de lamr on peut pas
l'inventer puisque c'est un nombre
d'athlètes effectivement on était très
en retard il y a quelques années
maintenant on a une un pôle médical qui
est plus complet ce qu'on a donné comme
élément c'est 74% de réalisation
complète peut-être ma question c'est
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire quand quand
on met autoévaluation fédération et on
met juste atteint ça veut dire quoi je
je peux pas vous
dire le contrat de délégation prévoit la
formalisation et la publication sur le
site internet de la FFA d'une procédure
ne signalement des violences incivilité
et discrimination pouvez-vous nous
décrire cette procédure et a-t-elle été
publiée sur le site internet au-delà du
signalement de quel dispositif d'écoute
de prise en charge et d'accompagnement
des victimes dispose la
FFA voilà nous avons signé une
convention avec colosse au pied d'argile
pour l'accompagnement pour le
signalement je crois qu'on a répondu
effectivement on a maintenant euh une
adresse mail spécifique qui n'est
peut-être pas bien visible sur le site
la directrice vous a dit qu'on
travaillait à la refonte du site pour le
rendre plus visile et pour
l'accompagnement on travaille avec
colosse au pied d'argille euh pour
l'accompagnement des athlètes justement
qui nous on qui qui viennent nous
trouver et qui nous ditent voilà qu'ils
ont des comm besoin ils on de
soutien mais il faut il faut reconnaître
quand même que sur les cas que je vous
ai je reviens sur les les violences
sexuelles sur les cas que je vous ai
transmis où on a pris parfois des des
décisions très fortes puisquon est allé
jusqu'à 40 ans de suspension on n pas eu
à ma connaissance je dis bien d'athlètes
qui ont demandé à être
accompagnés on n'a pas été sollicité
voilà
alors le contrat de délégation qui liit
la fédération à l'état indique que le
référent intégrité en collaboration avec
le comité d'éthique et de déontologie
doit établir et décliner un plan
d'action en particulier concernant les
violences sexuelles et les harcèlement
quelles mesures ont été mises en œuvre
dans ce plan dans le cadre de ce
plan c'est ce que c'est la feuille de
route que vous nous avez indiqué c'est
c'est voilà c'est le plan que je vous ai
évoqué tout à l'heure que nous sommes
progressivement en train de mettre en en
place je vous le redonne si vous voulez
hein mais c'est tous ces dispositifs
aujourd'hui
oui il y a la alors il y a la prise de
licence déjà je vous le dis donc
normalement chaque licencié doit lire le
comité d'éthique le la charte d'éthique
ensuite il y a le le signalement il y a
la sensibilisation la formation des
entraîneurs qui soi cts ou entraîneurs
fédéraux donc dans nos St dans nos
préparations nous allons amplifier nous
avons bien conscience que c'est un sujet
délicat nousm nous sommes près justement
à à remettre en question un certain
nombre de choses mais comme je vous l'ai
dit tout à l'heure nous sommes dans
depuis 2 ans dans une année préolympique
où on nous demande beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de choses nous avons fait
l'effort ce qui n'est pas le cas
malheureusement notutres fédérations qui
n'ont pas les moyens n nous avons fait
l'effort déjà de renforcer notre service
juridique c'est-à-dire que nous avons
créé un emploi spécifique déjà voilà ce
qui qui a été qui a été construit sur
sur no fonds propres voilà et et et nous
avons et nous avons créé dans chaque
ligue nous avonsé à chaque président de
créer un poste de référent
intégrité
et la Fédération a-t-elle communiqué sur
l'existence de signal sport et
comment chaque fois que nous avons eu un
cas qui a été déclaré qui est venu
jusqu'à nous ça a été déclaré à s SP
c'est pas la question c'est juste est-ce
que vous vous signalez à vos licenciés
est-ce que vos licenciés ont accès à
Signal
sport alors là sur le site de la
Fédération il y a effectivement un
onglet aide aux victimes qui renvoie à
Signal sport il faut cliquer sur
l'onglet il faut cliquer sur l'onglet il
n'y a pas signal sport d'indiquer en
première intention c'est pour ça qu'il
faut
revoir tout ça aussi peut-être corriger
également oui je pense que cette
commission d'enquête elle communique
largement sur la cellule du ministère
des Sports signal sport donc il faut il
faut œuvrer dans ce sens pour qu'il y
ait un message commun qui soit
maintenant notoriété une victime peut
faire un signalement sur signal sport on
simplifie en même temps l'accès et à
libérer la
parole peut-être question subidère
là-dessus est-ce que le ministère des
Sports vous a demandé de communiquer sur
signal sport
est-ce qu'on vous voilà est-ce qu'on
vous a demandé d'informer sur
l'existence de cette cellule de mémoire
dans la discussion qu'on a eu le 6 avril
il a été question de C sport la question
nous a été posée justement
et de de de communiquer et effectivement
comme vous l'a dit la directrice
générale c'est peut-être difficile à
trouver sur notre site mais ça figure
voilà on a on a évoqué au cours de cette
discussion on a évoqué sil SP
effectivement oui monsieur le Président
c'est pas communiqué quand ça fig mais
que c'est difficilement accessible c'est
pas communiquer sur la cellule il faut
valoriser la cellule signal sport et il
faut communiquer amplement sur la
cellule signal sport plus simplement
pour que ça soit accessible sans se
poser davantage de questions sû non mais
on on a conscience que le plan d'action
que je de prévention des violences que
je vous ai décrit on doit maintenant
accentuer on a parfaitement conscience
qu'on doit le faire mais je je vous
répète ce que j'ai dit tout à l'heure on
a aujourd'hui tellement de sujets à
aborder que on on essaie de faire le
maximum mais il y a voyez par
exemple ce matin a été annoncer la
grande cause nationale sur le sport hier
soir on a eu un webinaire avec les
présidents de féd et c'est très bien on
ne peut que se réjouir où on a un grand
nombre d'actions à mettre sur le terrain
y compris dans les quartiers difficiles
donc oui effectivement il y a il y a un
effort à faire on a vraiment conscience
qu'on a besoin de mettre beaucoup
d'accélérateur ça on en a conscience
mais c'est c'est vrai que on nous
demande beaucoup de choses en même temps
voilà donc ce pardon je voudrais revenir
sur le vous l'avez évoqué tout à l'heure
et je l'ai dit dans mon propos liminaire
sur la nécessité puisque vous nous avez
demandé si on peut faire des
propositions sur la nécessité dans le
cadre légal peut-être de mieux
coordonner toutes ces actions de
signalement chaque fédération
effectivement a son son dispositif plus
ou moins efficace on en convbien mais
c'est vrai que ça se dilue tout ça donc
on se un peu voyez c'est comme quand on
nous demande de nommer un référent
intégrité et qu'en même temps notre DTN
qui est pour rien à nommeré son propre
référent donc on on a deux référents à
l'intérieur de la même maison voyez donc
on a besoin vraiment on a besoin si
votre commission peut faire des
propositions là-dessus d'avoir un cadre
unique qui s'applique à toutes les
fédérations et ce qui évitera justement
ben c'est c'est qui proco qu'on a pu
entretenir
en fait sur sur la question de de de
signal sport il y a bien sûr alors déjà
normalement c'est censé être le rôle de
signal sport d'uniformiser à l'échelle
de toutes les fédérations une seule
entrée justement pour les signalements
et et et nous ce qu'on a constater
effectivement c'est que chaque
fédération a son propre outil parfois
avec un système de filtre plus ou moins
strict sur ce qui remonte ou pas à
Signal sport mais vous nous avez
indiqué avoir rencontré justement la
directrice Madame Bourdet il y a pas
très longtemps entre ces deux auditions
est-ce que par exemple elle vous a
indiqué puisque nous on a pu constater
le manque d'information autour de signal
sport est-ce qu'elle vous a demandé
d'améliorer la communication et
l'information autour du dispositif
signal sport oui effectivement oui ça a
été évoqué oui monsieur le Président
est-ce que vous pouvez mettre votre
micro bien au niveau de votre bouche
voilà pardon oui ça a été ça a été
évoqué pense excusez-moi mais je pense
qu'on a on a tous les
les le même intérêt pour que ça
progresse rapidement comme je vous l'ai
dit tout à l'heure il y a un peu de
confusion dans tous les dispositif il y
a besoin de
clarification mais dans dans le tableau
que vous avez vous voyez bien fin
égement madame baiss un peu votre micro
voilà euh que ça ça peut venir de
plusieurs euh enfin les les informations
peuvent arriver de signal sport de la
fédération du CED
euh donc on se rend bien compte qu'en
fait c'est pas une seule adresse mais
plusieurs finalement
oui tout à fait mais je vous pose la
question parce que je je revérifie le
tableau mais je ne crois pas dans ce
tblon voir l'onglet signal sport en fait
cellule de signalement et en fait la
question c'est pas tellement vous mais
c'est tellement comment ce que le
ministère des Sports met un outil en
place et non on fait pas l'évaluation
auprès des fédérations mais peut-être
que j'ai raté
l'onglet pardon oui j'en vois un là déjà
2023 2 cinesport André Girot cinesport
André girud ou ou pour les dossiers RAL
à
Seng ah pardon excusez-moi alors on
parle pas du même tableau moi je parle
du tableau
d'évaluation des actions cont voilà
c'est pas celui-ci donc ça on a bien vu
les signalements qui ont été faits en
fait c'est comment le ministère évalue
vos actions donc on nous a dit que il y
avait un tableau qui avait été envoyé
avec des items dans lequel la Fédération
devait remplir ce qui avait été réalisé
et dans les différents items y compris
d'ailleurs dans
[Musique]
lutte contre les violences par exemple
on voit pas on aurait pu avoir un item
information autour de la cellule signal
sport c'est pas le cas donc c'est c'est
juste ça c'estàd comment est-ce qu'on
évalue des outils lorsque y compris dans
les items en fait il n'apparaissent pas
ça ça c'est plutôt la direction
technique nationale qui pourrait
préciser cette question là en tout cas
oui oui mais c'est c'est c'est le cas
c'est pour ça qu'on c'est pour ça qu'on
vous demander siil vous avait été fait
remarque de l'information autour de la
cellule signal sport c'està dire que ça
a été fait à l'oral mais ça n'apparaît
pas dans le tableau
d'évaluation normalement pas à suite à
cette audition du 6 avril on a demandé à
Fabienne Bordet de nous adresser un
courrier sur tout ce qui est amélioré on
a on a eu 10 items he au cours de cette
réunion le haut niveau enfin on a tout
abordé et le SMR par exemple on lui a
demandé de nous faire un courrier pour
mettre la pression justement sur votre
commission
médicale alors peut-être sur la
commission disciplinaire de première
instance donc votre site internet recens
les décisions la plupart des décisions
les plus récentes de la commission
disciplinaire de première instance
disponible sur votre site Internet
relève de comportement inappropriés
verbaux ou physiques notamment sexuel
donc ça représente qure desci c de
juillet 2023 il s'agit très souvent de
comportement d'entraîneur à l'égard des
sportives alors du coup la question
c'est est-ce que l'athlétisme est un
sport plus touché que les autres par les
VSS et si oui selon vous qu'est-ce qu'il
explique alors j'ai des difficultés à
répondre comparé par rapport aux autres
sports c'est sûr que je me suis pas
penché sur le nombre de cas des autres
sports c'est vrai que dans les sports
individuels ça je vous donne mon avis
personnel hein euh c'est beaucoup plus
disons fréquent à mon avis que dans les
sports collectifs ça c'est une évidence
j'en ai discuté avec certains collègues
de fédération nous avons nous un sport
individuel ou en dehors des groupes
alors je parle de tous les pratiquants
pas que du haut niveau hein pratique
générale en club il y a des groupes
d'entraînement avec plusieurs
disciplines les sauteurs les lanceurs
les coururs de demi-fond les sprinterurs
quand les athlètes sont en groupe
on a d'après les cas qu'on a qu'on a eu
on n pas eu trop de problèmes c'est
lorsque l'athlète a un entraîneur ou où
l'athlète féminin a un entraîneur
masculin avec disons des des parcours
individualisés en dehors parfois du club
avec des stages qui peuvent se dérouler
en dehors du club que nous ne maîtrisons
pas parce que il il ne nous disent pas
qu'il partent en stage voyez un athlète
de niveau régional qui part en stage
avec un entraîneur ou deux athlètes avec
un entraîneur on n'est pas au courant il
nous disait pas qu'il partte en stage il
peut y avoir des cas dans les cas que
nous avons traités c'est surtout des cas
comme ça qui ont été traités des
signalements que nous avons traité
immédiatement et que nous avons
sanctionné d'ailleurs très
fortement la FFA s'est-elle déjà
constituée partie civile dans une
affaire concernant l'un ou l'une de ces
licenciés quelle était la nature de
l'affaire
oui alors je pouvais pas vous dire le
nombre de cas mais ça nous est arrivé en
matière de
dopage principalement en matière de
dopage parce que c'était l'image de la
Fédération aussi qui était et pareil je
vous dis exactement on a souvent été mis
en cause
par des athlètes qui partaient en stage
individuel et nous rendant responsable
alors que on ne savait même pas où il se
trouvait la liberté de circulation
existe dans notre pays on pe pas
empêcher un athlète de partir avec son
entraîneur d'aller faire un stage au
Mexique au Maroc aux États-Unis et on a
eu quelques cas comme ça où on s'est
constitué partie civile pour atteindre
l'image de la
fédération
et vous avez eu retour vous avez pu
échanger par la suite oui oui mon sieur
on a on a eu on a eu
disons dans dans on a eu une affaire
aussi avec une athlète sur des des
problèmes financiers je crois et on
s'est constituer partie civile on a
gagné alors justement sur les différents
cas de VSS vous n'êtes pas parti civile
sur aucune de ces affaires
oui effectivement on s'était posé la
question et juridiquement la la
constitution de parti civil dans le
cadre des affaires de violence sexuelle
sont quasi systématiquement refusé par
les juges et donc la plainte de la
victime présumée a été déposée par
exemple quand on a eu l'affaire de camp
là
euh ça a été déposé après donc c'est
pour ça qu'on on se constitue pas parti
civil ah oui pardon alors juste pour
vous préciser en fait la Fédération de
tennis le fait donc y compris sur des
affaires de violence sexuelle et sexiste
des agressions sexuelles et juste avant
vous on a reçu la fédération de natation
qui ont été pour qui ça a été refusé la
première fois ils ont fait appel ils ont
obtenu gain de cause ils sont bien
partis civil sur une affaire pour
accompagner une victime de VSS donc vous
pouvez tout à fait le faire
aussi une question de Stéphane Mazard
oui merci madame la Présidente justement
monsieur le Président c'est un peu la
question que je voulais vous vous enin
c'était la réflexion que je voulais vous
faire en disant il faut peut-être
insister et et la question que je vous
pose c'est de savoir justement selon
vous est-ce qu'il y aurait un intérêt
àer jusqu'au bout de cette démarche de
se constituer partie civile ce qui vous
permet quand même d'accéder au dossier
et de faire valoir
les droits ou l'image les droits et
l'image de la de la FD donc voilà est-ce
que pour vous c'est un enjeu important
et et si oui pourquoi et puis peut-être
ma question parce qu'on arrive au terme
de cette commission d'enquête l'idée
madame la rapporteur madame la
Présidente et Madame la rapporteur vont
nous faire des propositions avec une
réflexion qui sera aussi collective sur
les amélioration à apportter donc à
notre système ou à nos systèmes pour
pour mieux pour mieux lutter contre
contre ces violences ou contre ces ces
exactions de manière plus générale euh
est-ce que euh vous avez des
préconisations à faire pour améliorer
euh vous la gestion de votre FD
l'organisation de votre FD et et est-ce
que ça vous semble suffisamment CLA
l'articulation que vous devez faire
entre les procédures administratives les
procédures disciplinair et puis les
procédures judiciaires euh quand on sait
que la temporalité n'est pas la même
qu'il y a des principes qu'il faut
appréhender qui sont pas toujours très
simples ceux de la présomption
d'innocence
euh de la nécessité de préserver les
intérêts du d'une victime supposée enfin
voilà donc est-ce que tout ça vous
semble suffisamment clair et et
suffisamment facile à à à appréhender
oui alors vre première question
effectivement et je prends bien note des
propos de Madame la rapporteur
concernant la constitution de parti
civil bien sûr que nous allons nous
engouffrer là-dedans parce que au moins
on aura accès au dossier et ça nous
permettra ça nous permettra de mieux
traiter les dossiers disciplinaires
euh donc on est favorable on est
favorable je vous dis on a eu quelques
cas pour le dopage mais pourquoi pas sur
les violences sexuelles le deuxième le
deuxème aspect que vous avez évoqué et
qui me semble tout aussi important c'est
la
temporalité nous dans le code du sport
on nous demande en 10 semaines en 10
semaines de TR traiter des cas
disciplinaires sous toutes ces formes or
le temps le temps judiciaire de notre
pays que ce soit la police ou la justice
ça prend des mois parfois des années
voyez y compris je l'ai dit d'ailleurs
au cours du propos liminire la première
fois y compris sur les cas de dopage
quand nous traitions nous-même les cas
de dopage les suspensions Inter
intervenit dans les 10 semaines
aujourd'hui nous avons en cours des
athlètes qui sont soupçonnés de dobage
et il faut attendre 2 ans avant deall
les sanctionner on a plus le droit de
les sanctionner voyez donc il faut
améliorer tout ça oui effectivement on a
besoin d'avoir des circuits plus courts
à tous les niveaux des circuits plus
courts auprès desquels on est prêt à
collaborer voyz donc je prends cet
exemple de la FLD et je jette pas la
pierre à la FLD parce qu'on travaille
bien mais on a le cas aujourd'hui d'un
athlète qui a été confondu pour des
nocha HE comme on dit il y a 2 ans et
qui est toujours pas sanctionné donc
qu'est-ce qui se passe c'est que si on
le suspend nous-même aujourd'hui d'abord
on a pas le droit c'est la FLD qui le
fait l'athlète peut se retourner contre
nous au tribunal en disant mais pourquoi
vous m'empêchez de participer à un
championnat et si cet athlète est
sanctionné par la FLD dans 2 ans toutes
les performances qu'il aura réalisé y
compris si on a des médailles seront
annulé voyez on a on a un problème dans
les propositions que je voudrais faire à
la commission c'est que on arrive à
uniformiser et à rendre le la
temporalité disons plus restreinte sur
tous ces problèmes que ce soit traité
beaucoup plus rapidement voilà c'est
c'est le problème malheureusement c'est
pas uniquement pour le sport
d'ailleurs c'est un problème qu'il faut
qu'on arrive à travailler ensemble pour
ça que je disais tout à l'heure on a un
cadre légal qui est serré qui est
complexe et puis pour vous dire aussi
que nous sommes au tout début parce que
franchement tous ces problèmes-l de
violence sexuelle je parle pas pas des
violences d' civilité parce que ça ça
dure depuis des années on les traite
mais le problème des violence sexuelle
c'est récent ça ça date de 3 4 ans quoi
et la la parole se libère est en mieux
mais on éétait pas prêt on était pas
prêt alors nous on a fait l'effort de
renforcer le service juridique c'est
vrai on a fait avec les moyens dont nous
disposion juridiquement mais on a
parfaitement conscience qu'on a besoin
de coordonner tout ça avec les autres
fédérations et avec le ministère des
sport on en a vraiment
conscience une question de Monsieur
Stéphan
bûchou merci merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le
Président rapidement moi je je je vais
pas épiloguer mais je bon je je regrette
à l'instar de ce qu'a pu dire Madame la
la rapporteur les messages qu' on pu
être diffusés à l'issue de la première
audition je pense que c'est pas à la
hauteur des travaux qui sont les
nôtres de l'audition qui a été mené ici
et des enjeux
surtout qui
sont qui sont traités dans cette dans
cette commission voilà donc moi je je je
tenais à le dire on passe on passe pas
autant de temps sur sur ces sujets làà
pour pour au final se se voir et
gratiger de la sorte
premier point deuxème
[Musique]
point lorsque vous dites tout à l'heure
que vous avez rencontré Madame Bourdet
entre les deux auditions et que le sujet
de l'amélioration des dispositifs a a
fait l'objet d'une d'un échange entre
vous vous avez dit en réponse à à Madame
la rapporteur ou madame la Présidente je
ne sais plus que le sujet avait été
évoqué de l'axe d'amélioration et et je
voulais savoir ce que vous mettez
derrière le mot évoquer est-ce est-ce
qu'il y a est-ce qu'il y a un plan de un
plan qui a été qui a été mis en œuvre
pensé enfin est-ce que vous êtes en
mesure de nous de nous donner plus de
détails ou est-ce que ça fait juste
l'objet d'un et c'est pas du tout encore
une fois un jugement dans ma bouche mais
où est-ce que c'est juste un échange qui
a eu qui a eu lieu entre la directrice
des sports et le président de la FD en
se disant bah il faut qu'on se revoie
pour pour aller plus dans le détail ça
c'est ma première ma première question
ma seconde question c'est euh
euh ce matin dans la presse locale dans
le département dont je suis déélu
rappelle la Vendé euh il est fait état
d'un d'une décision qui euh qui est
tombée tard je reprends les terme de de
l'article de presse qui est tombé tard
dans la soirée sur un entraîneur
d'athlétisme euh qui euh qui a été
condamné euh pour des agressions
sexuelles et sexistes à euh 2
de prison avec surc interdiction
d'exercer toute activité en lien avec
des mineurs je voulais savoir si vous
aviez alors pour des fait qui a priori
remonte à 2015 o en tous les cas il y
avait une plainte qui avait été déposée
en 2015 donc je voulais savoir si vous
aviez eu si vous aviez eu un
connaissance au sein de la fédération de
des agissements de ce monsieur je pense
que c'est un monsieur à priori hein et
et
deuxièmement est-ce qu'on peut être
aujourd'hui assuré que compte tenu de
cette condamnation il n'exerce plus
jamais de
fonction à la fois dans l'athlétisme
mais aussi dans d'autres sports c'est
une question un peu un peu large mais
voilà
merci
excusez-moi voilà pardon alors pour la
première question peut-être que vous
êtes arrivé tout à l'heure j'en avais
parlé je sais pas on a un plan de
prévention des violences qui a été
évoqué avec Fabien Bordet c'est ce que
j'ai dit hein nous avons évoqué ce plan
nous lui avons transmis il est en cours
de réalisation il y a des des actions
qui sont déjà conduites d'autres que
nous entendons conduire ça a été dit par
ma directrice générale nous sommes en
train de refondre complètement notre
site internet parce que ça devient un
fouilli même pour les résultats on a du
mal à les retrouver donc là vraiment on
a un vrai plan de prévention qu'on peut
vous remettre d'ailleurs qu'on a remis à
Fabien Bordet qu'on peut vous remettre
qui est vraiment euh acté par le DTN et
par nous-même ça c'est sûr pour le
dossier dont vous parlez bien sûr qu'on
est au courant c'est un dossier qui est
en cours par la commission de discipline
voyez c'est une cisine qui est en cours
donc nous on a été informé par euh le le
président de la ligue locale hein et
donc on a saisi la commission de
discipline mais en même temps il y a une
enquête puis il y a eu une condamnation
qui est tombée hein voilà donc ce
dossier sera traité et je peux vous
assurer que comme nous l'avons fait sur
notre dossier il est pas question pour
nous qu'il continue à entraîner ou qu'il
exerce d'ailleurs après on le signale
aux différentes ligues on a eu un cas il
y a 2 ans je crois d'un d'un cadre
fédéral qui avait changé de lieu de
Bordeaux vers la Bretagne voyez de la
kiten vers la Bretagne et qui s'était
faufilé entre les mailles du filet dans
un petit club ça nous a été signalé on a
stoppé tout de suite voyz dès que dès
qu'on connaît voilà il y a toujours des
des des cas comme ça qu'on essaie de
mais c'est vrai que on a été saisi sur
ce dossier et que l're commiss euh
il y a pas très longtemps
hein la date vous donnez la date he
normalement on a 10 semaines pour le
traité mais on a tellement de cas qui
arrivent que chaque fois on on a on a
été on a été saisi c'est
sûr et et juste pour le rendez-vous avec
la directrice desesport il était prévu
hein de longues dates pour faire un
point sur sur la délégation c'était pas
lié c'était pas lié à notre audition qui
était prévu ici également quoi non non
mais juste sur le alors du coup sur ma
sur ma première
question non non non c'était pas une
question d'ailleurs c'était une
observation non sur la première question
et et pas sur le premier point sur la
première question ça ça appelait pas
forcément de commentaire mais si vous en
avez un je je prends évidemment sur la
première question sur en fait c'était
une question sur le simplement sur le
mot évoqué est-ce que certes je suis
arrivé en retard mais j'ai j'ai bien
pris connaissance des différents
échanges que vous avez pu avoir et sur
la la refondte de votre site internet et
cetera et cetera mais ma question
portait plus au final
sur le sujet un peu précis de de signal
sport et et de tout ce qui tourne autour
parce que c'est vrai que au-delà de la
Fédération Française d'Athlétisme on se
rend compte mais ça a été très bien
expliqué donc je vais pas y revenir que
ce n'est pas appréhendé de la même
manière au sein de au sein de toutes les
fédérations et que je pense que
effectivement et c'est peut-être ce vers
quoi il faut tendre c'est une forme
d'harmonisation avec en en ligne de mire
quand même la priorité donné aux
victimes de manière à ce que ce soit
simple et
simplifié bon voilà pour pour pour la
première question et juste je reviens
sur sur la la deuxième question
euh donc quand vous dites on a été on a
été informé il y a il n'y a pas très
longtemps et alors moi je encore une
fois sans sans jugement de ma part quand
je lis l'article alors sous réserve que
les informations soient les bonnes dans
l'article que j'ai lu euh il est fait
état d'une d'un dépôt de plainte en 2015
ça fait 8 ans et çaà dire
qu'entre que vous vous avez été informé
bien après
d'accord la date
précise c'est 5 avril 2023 par signal
sport signal sport
voilà 5 avril
oui alors juste peut-être pour précis
les choses donc la plainte est déposée
en 2015 vous êtes prévenu par signal
sport en 2023 au moment où vous êtes
prévenu par signal sport est-ce que vous
avez tenté de comprendre à quel moment
signal sport enfin à quel moment le
ministère des Sports était informé de
cette plainte non je veux pas vous
répondre je sais pas exactement nous on
a on a on a donné la la commission de
discipline pour inststruction comme on
fait d'habitude vous voyez je j'apprends
aujourd'hui par par Monsieur le Député
j'apprends que ça date de 2015 je savais
pas
alors c'est vrai que c'est compliqué
mais c'est c'est simplement pour
comprendre parce que on est on est
vraiment je pense là au cœur au cœur des
des des problèmes et alors après encore
une fois moi je je il faut rester
prudent parce que c'est c'est un article
de presse donc il faudra avoir les faits
tels qu'ils se sont réellement déroulés
mais ce que j'en lis en tous les cas et
je je je vous le lis tel quel c'est que
il y a effectivement eu un une plainte
déposée en 2015 une plainte qui a été
classé sans suite je je viens de voir
qu'elle a été classée sans suite et la
procureure s'exprimant sur l'affaire dit
il a perpétré les mêmes comportements
déviant pendant 20 ans alors je sais pas
depuis
quand il exerçait ses fonctions mais
effectivement en tous les cas je pense
que ça nous interroge collectivement sur
le fait que entre un dépôt de plainte
même si elle a été classée sans suite en
2015 et
votre et votre finalement enfin celui
qui vous est remonté 8 ans
après là on a quand même un souci
quoi je suis tout à fait d'accord avec
vous je vous dis c'est pour ça que dans
les propositions que la Commission va
être amenée à faire il faut qu'on arrive
à trouver le bon circuit faut vraiment
trouver le bon circuit comme je disais
que ce
soit non alors l'explication d'après ce
que vous me dites j'ai lu l'article que
comme vous
l'explication c'est là aussi c'est un
ressenti personnel que je vais vous
donner c'est que comme il y a eu une un
classement s suite en 2015 ça n'a jamais
été signalé je pense hein ça même au
niveau local parce qu'on a des comités
départementaux on a des ligue on a des
présidents de ligue qui sont aussi à
alerté quand il y a un problème donc je
pense que à partir de là rien a été
signalé rien n'est remonté jusqu'à la
Fédération voyez je pense que mais c'est
un ressenti personnel hein bien sûr ça
reste incroyable euh bon moi je je je
encore une fois j'entends ça et et je
suis juste dans dans une réflexion un
peu à voix haute et et d'essayer de me
dire comment est-ce qu'on peut comment
est-ce qu'on peut améliorer les choses
comme vous le dites c'est un ressenti
est-ce que vous aujourd'hui compenu de
cette affaire qui est quand même grave
avec une condamnation malgré tout est-ce
que vous vous avez aujourd'hui euh les
moyens et surtout l'envie d'investiguer
parce que ça remonte pas non plus à à à
il y a 20 ans ça remonte à il y a 8 ans
on peut peut-être imaginer que les
personnes en poste aujourd'hui en place
l'était déjà en 2015 euh est-ce est-ce
qu'il est envisageable que vous
digigentiez une
enquête ou que vous fassiez digenter une
enquête pour savoir à minima ce qui ce
qui a dfonctionné qu'est-ce qui fait
qu'à un moment donné au sein de ce club
au sein de cette ligue même si l'affaire
même si pardon la plainte a été classée
sans suite à aucun moment euh vous
n'ayez été informé et et quit des
victimes peut-être entendre les victimes
pour savoir si elles elles avaient euh
elles avaient témoigné moi je vous donne
un exemple alors encore une fois je vous
dis ça c'est AB brute pour point et et
et c'est c'est simplement pour qu'on
réfléchisse collectivement
euh imaginons que les victimes en
question
et témoigner soit aller se confier au
président du club au président de la
ligue je ne sais pas et que même n'est
rien fait et que ces mêmes personnes
aujourd'hui sont en poste ça pose quand
même question et vousmême au sein de
votre votre fonctionnement de fédération
je pense que il y a là peut-être matière
à à à tracer pour savoir ce qui
réellement s'est
passé peut-être avant avec un petit
bémol aussi quand même parce que dans on
est dans la vraie vie quand même on est
en
2015 imaginons effectivement ça vient
jusqu'aux oreilles du président ou d'un
éducateur euh il y a une enquête
puisqu'il y a un classement sansite et
là pour le
coup on peut pas être plus ENF on se met
dans la peau du bénévole qui peut pas
faire plus quoi il y a une enquête il y
a un classement sans suite c'est des
professionnels on est en 2015 qu'est-ce
que vous
voulezement pour répondre alors déjà
votre question est-ce qu'on a l'envie
oui oui on a l'envie d'en savoir plus ça
c'est sûr euh les alors le le le
président de la ligue n'est plus le même
hein depuis 2015 c'est les Pays de la
Loire donc et et mais je il est toujours
il est toujours disons dans le cercle
fédéral il est plus président mais je
lui poserai la question hein déjà à
titre personnel pour savoir s'il avait
été informé de ce cas parce que moi j'ai
découvert l'article comme enfin ça ça
est arrivé et j'ai envoyé en commission
de discipline et j'ai vu l'article ce
matin j'ai même vu que il y avait
silence en radio du comité de la Ligue
ENF le journaliste c'est ce qui écrit le
journaliste j'ai j'ai bien lu donc
l'envie et là on va essayer de
comprendre ce qui s'est passé et comme
disait monsieur le député alors en terme
de moyens non je vous dis franchement on
n' pas les moyens aujourd'hui
d'investiguer je vous dis on a créé
alors on a créé un poste de travail de
juristes
complémentaire un emploi carrément que
pour ça et il y a pas beaucoup de
fédérations qui l'ont fait sur le fonds
propres on a investi 12000 € avec
colosse auprès d'argile colosse prè
d'argile ça fait quand même des sommes
importantes et on n pas les moyens
humains je le disais d'ailleurs mon prop
limininaire aujourd'hui on n' pas les
moyens humains de faire le travail de la
police voyez c'est vrai que là aussi
c'est des propositions à faire dans vous
voyez alors une proposition que je
pourrais faire mais là aussi euh vous
savez dans dans le cadre du du plan
Sport
Emploi il y a aujourd'hui des créations
d'emploi si euh et qui sont aidés par
l'État pendant 3 ans avant d'être
pérénisé pour les éducateurs pour les
entraîneurs moi je fais une proposition
qu'on affecte à toutes les fédérations
il y a 110 fédérations en France et bien
qu'on nous crée 110 emplois et on est
prêt à les prendre voyez c'est
aujourd'hui il y a on veut développer
l'emploi on veut développer l'emploi
sportif on on s'oriente vers les emplois
dans les quartiers dans très bien hein
mais pourquoi pourquoi ne pas avoir au
sein des fédérations des juristes
complémentaires avec une aide qui serait
apportée par l'État aujourd'hui pour
pouvoir créer ses emplois aujourd'hui
les moyens financiers des féération ne
permettent pas de créer x emploi voyez
et c'est vrai qu'on est on n pas on n
pas été formé non plus euh pour
investiguer mais ça devient nécessaire
effectivement alors juste peut-être
avant de que mon que mon collègue
reprenne la parole
euh en réalité nous ce qu'on constate et
ce qui nous interroge et d'ailleurs tous
collectivement je pense à peu à peu près
c'est que il y a des affaires qui
émergent qu'on découvre parfois quelques
années après même souvent et ce dont on
se rend compte aussi c'est qu'il y avait
des personnes qui étaient informées au
moment des faits qui n'ont rien dit et
qui n'ont pas fait remonter les
informations donc nous quand on pose la
question de savoir est-ce que vous
pouvez vous renseigner pour savoir ce
qui s'est passé c'est aussi pour pouvoir
identifier pourquoi à ce moment-là
précisément voilà l'information n'est
pas remontée parce que la réalité c'est
que dans tout quasiment toutes les
affaires qu'on a pu voir ici bah soit il
y avait un bruit soit il y avait une
information persistante soit il y avait
des personnes qui étaient au courant et
qui n'ont rien dit et moi je je l'ai
souvent dit mais je vais le redire
encore une fois être témoin ou être
infer de faits graves tels que peuvent
être des agressions sexuelles et ne rien
dire est une complicité c'est un moment
c'est aussi une responsabilité des
dirigeants des clubs des entraîneurs des
adultes qui sont présents sur les sites
et qui sont informés et c'est là où en
fait peut-être effectivement ça pose une
question sur les moyens les vôtres ceux
des fédérations mais aussi ceux du
ministère des Sports euh par le biais
des dragess et par les dispositifs de
contrôle au niveau des départements et
des régions pour pouvoir faire ces
contrôles et pouvoir comprendre pourquoi
un certain moment bien oui il y a des
failles dans le système qui font qu'on
n' pas les informations au bon moment
parce que là on parle d'une personne qui
a agi pendant 20 ans mais dans le foot
c'est pareil c'est des personnes qui ont
violé des mineurs pendant X années et
dans d'autres disciplines on se rend
compte aussi que c'est la même chose
donc si à un moment un adulte avait
parlé et bien peut-être que que les
choses se seraient arrêtées alors je
sais pas si le président l'a dit tout à
l'heure mais c'est pour ça qu'on a
intégré dans notre code éthique la
possibilité qu'un licencié quand il est
au courant de quelque chose doit en
informer la Fédération et si on apprend
finalement qu' non que le licencié en
question n'a pas informé la la
fédération ou la ligue ou le club il
peut être sanctionné espèce de d'article
40 pour les
licenciés vous vous confirmez bien que
vous n'aviez aucune information
sur ce comportement on va dire dans le
club qu'on connaît parce que il s'agit
de la CLR donc chez moi la Roch suron
vous n'aviez eu aucune
information on a jamais eu alors
j'interrogerai madame la Présidente le
président de la ligue que vous
connaissez aussi puisque c'est votre
région que je qui travaille toujours
avec nous he sur d'autres missions je
lui pose réement la question mais je
n'avais aucune aucune information là
non c'était
plus sous forme d'observation
c'est-à-dire que là vous êtes prévenu
certes qu'en 2023 mais un petit peu
quand même avant l'audience là
typiquement c'est vrai que vous auriez
pu éventuellement solliciter une copie
du dossier pour pouvoir vous constituer
partie civile quit à ce qu' l'audience
on l'a déclaré recevable mais ça vous
permett d'accéder au dossier et
peut-être vous de vous faire une
conviction sur ce qui a disfonction
donné voilà et je pense qu'il y a un
vrai sujet sur la possibilité pour les
féd de se constituer partie civile et
d'avoir accès au dossier pour faire des
retours sur expérience surtout que là on
est sur des dossiers qui
arrivent sur la
base d'une information qui était pas
celle d'aujourd'hui de procédures pour
lesquelles on nait pas une attention
très particulière jusqu'alors et donc ça
mériterait vraiment pour les dossiers
qui arrivent à la barre des tribunaux
aujourd'hui d'avoir C capacité de
rentrer dans ces dossiers et de regarder
ce qui a disfonctionner et ça permet
d'avoir encore une fois ce retour
d'expérience utile pour
l'avenir c'est c'est vrai que ben on va
s'y intéresser mais je vous cache pas
que en dehors des 35 dossiers nous avons
encore se ou h dossiers en cours
actuellement he qui sont pas làdedans et
que ça demande des moyens je vous dis si
bien qu'on n arrive plus alors pour ce
qui est notre métier de cœur voyez on
est en train de travailler sur sur la
réforme des statuts des ligues et des
comités pour aller vers la parité on a
été une fédération je rends hommage à
mon prédécesseur à instaurer la parité
avant qu'elle soit rendue obligatoire
donc chez nous c'est le deuxème le 3è
mandat d'ailleurs oui c'est le TR c'est
le 3è mandat où il y a parité dans
toutes les instances fédérales
nationales mais pas dans les ligues et
dans les comités donc on est en train de
revoir aujourd'hui avec les services
juridiques les statuts des ligues et des
comités pour imposer dès la dès les
élections 2024 la parité y compris dans
les départements et ben on n'a pas le
temps de travailler sur ces statuts
parce que la personne que nous avons
embauché elle est absorbée par les
dossiers qui remontent sur les violences
vous voyez donc le le manque de moyens
réel des fédérations existe ou alors à
un moment il faut nous dire vous vous
occupez plus je sais pas vous vous
occupez plus du haut niveau vous laissez
le haut niveau de côté et et vous faites
le reste quoi mais c'est qu' on a on a
un champ énorme je disais tout à l'heure
dans la grande cause nationale du sport
pour laquelle on a adhéré à 150 % je
fais partie parce que j'ai j'ai une
expérience dans ce domaine là je fais
partie des militants de la politique de
la ville et des quartiers parce que je
suis issu de ces quartiers à Marseille
et que ça me tient à cœur je me suis
investi dans la
professionnalisation de nos cadres pour
faire faire de l'athlétisme dans les
quartiers
c'est un dossier énorme et je peux pas
tout faire en même temps voyez donc on
essaie dans notre organisation de
répondre à toutes les questions mais
c'est vrai qu'on nous demande beaucoup
de choses et que on n' pas toujours les
moyens de d'aller au bout voilà mais on
est vraiment conscient que il y a il y a
de réels progrès à faire d'autant je
vous dis que on a continuellement des
dossiers qui
remontent dans le cadre des différentes
auditions il y a plusieurs acteurs qui
ont évoqué en tout cas qui ont proposé
l'idée d'une autorité indépendante pour
gérer toutes ces affaires justement euh
qui prennent du temps vous l'avez dit et
qui demandent des moyens et des
compétences alors même que vous êtes une
fédération qui n'est pas qui fait pas
partie des plus petites j'imagine le
poids que ça doit représenter pour des
fédérations qui sont encore plus petites
que la vôtre justement on aimerait avoir
votre avis là-dessus sur cette autorité
indépendante écoutez moi moi je serais
très je suis très favorable à ce qu'il y
ait une autorité indépendante qui soit
créée et qui qui nous permettent de
régler mieux ces problèmes avec les
spécialistes avec les
juristes nous on pourrait au lieu de
transmettre à nos
commissions habituelles on pourrait leur
transmettre le dossier ça serait
beaucoup plus facile pour nous
effectivement
oui et puis tout le monde serait traité
de la même façon voyez je reviens à la
FLD excusez-moi mais c'est c'est un
exemple qui peut servir la FLD jusqu'en
2019 euh c'était les fédérations qui
sanctionnaient le dopage c'est chaque
fédération qui avait ses cas de dopage
évaluer alors il y avait des fédérations
qui mettaient 2 ans d'autres 3 ans de
suspension d'autres qui cachaient le
dopage donc la FLD a tout repris en main
aujourd'hui c'est les mêmes sanctions
pour le dopage pour tous les sportifs
quel qu'il soit alors qu'avant c'était
pas le cas voyez donc effectivement si
on avait une
institution prête à à nous aider
là-dessus on est vraiment partant il y a
pas de
problème peut-être une question sur le
contrôle d'honorabilité parce que c'est
aussi un outil qui a été mis en
place et sur lequel on a eu des retours
très différent j'ai pu constater en
faisant le contrôle sur place aussi les
difficultés
donc peut-être plusieurs questions la
première c'est où est-ce que vous en
êtes vous aujourd'hui du contrôle
d'honorabilité euh je vous pose des
questions parce que dans le tableau
d'évaluation qui a été transmis il y a
écrit attend
euh donc pareil même question que pour
le suivi médical donc qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire atteint et peut-être les
difficultés rencontrées lors de ces
contrôles d'honorabilité
oui alors en 2021 on avait quand on
avait fait 83 contrôles ENF
d'honorabilité c'était le dispositif le
test de dispositif en 2022
6698 et en 2023 on est à
10476 euh ont été soumis des dirigeants
et des
entraîneurs je peux vous donner le nom
7126 dirigeants 3350 entraîneurs d'après
alors je connais pas les chiffres des
autres fédérations d'après la Réunion
qu'on a eu avec Fabien
Bordet c'est encore insuffisant mais
nous ne sommes pas en retard par ort à
d'autres fédérations c'est ce qui nous a
été dit hein on a passé la barre des
20000 en ah aujourd'hui non enfin la
semaine dernière la semaine dernière on
aurait passé la barre des 20000 on me
dit voyez on continue voilà on continue
à travailler
là-dessus ah oui donc la barre des 20000
c'est sur les 3 ans c'est en cumulé
juste pour cette année c'est pour 2023
d'ailleurs la direction des sports avait
trouvé effectivement le chiffre de 10000
qui étit pas très important
proportionnellement au nombre de
licenciés à la Fédération et qu'on était
plus finalement sur on devrait être plus
sur un nombre de autour de de de 30000
donc on a passé en fait la la barre des
20000 la semaine
dernière euh alors au moment du contrôle
sur place justement euh moi j'avais vu
donc sur ce contrôle d'honorabilité des
retours de centaines de mail euh euh
puisque en fait voilà quand on entre les
informations ensuite on a un retour qui
demande énormément de temps de
traitement est-ce que c'est des
informations en tout cas des difficultés
que vous avez fait remonter au ministère
des Sports et quelle a été leur réponse
là-du est-ce qu'il y a euh une réflexion
pour l'amélioration du dispositif en
tant que tel alors pour répondre à votre
première question oui nous avons fait
remonter les difficultés que vous avez
évoqué d'ailleurs que vous avez constaté
vous-même avec le logiciel hein qui est
parfois Ren et on arrive pas au bout qui
décourage d'ailleurs certains dirigeants
parce qu'ils arrivent pas à se connecter
enfin c'est on a effectivement soulevé
le problème on nous a dit que le
problème était pris en compte que ça
allait s'améliorer mais c'est vrai que
le logiciel actuel est est compliqué à
manipuler voilà mais on nous a donné des
garanties que ça allait s'améliorer
c'est justement quand on nous a dit que
avec 10000 cas on était en retard et que
sur une fédération de 300000 licenciés
on devrait avoir au moins 30000 contrôle
bon là on vient de passer la barre des
20000 et T mieux ça progresse mais on a
beaucoup de
rejets on vous a donné un délai sur euh
l'amélioration du logiciel parce que là
maintenant ça fait quand même quelques
années non ils ont pris en compte nos
remarques mais on était pas les seuls à
formuler
hein
alors
euh justement je vais revenir sur le
tableau puisque vous n'avez pas
forcément répondu à la question quand il
est indiqué à temps sur le contrôle
d'honorabilité ça correspond à quoi
parce qu'il y a pas de pourcentage donc
est-ce que vous est-ce que ça veut dire
que vous avez contrôlé toutes les
personnes qui devraient être dans le
casadre du contrôle d'honorabilité ou
est-ce que vous estimez que c'est
satisfaisant en terme de nombre de
personnes qui ont été contrôlés euh
j'imagine puisqueévidemment c'est pas
nous qui avons rempli c'est c'est le
service de la Direction Technique
National et en même temps on travaille
ensemble hein que ça veut dire que on a
réalisé ce contrôle d'honorabilité sans
forcément de d'objectifs précis en
revanche comme je vous le disais tout à
l'heure lorsqu'on a eu cette réunion à
la Direction des Sports euh on s'est
intéressé à ce chiffre de 10000 qu'on
trouvait pas assez important par rapport
au nombre de licenciers qu'on pourrait
plutôt être autour de de 30000
aujourd'hui on est à 20000 donc mais il
faut que en fait les systèmes puissent
se mettre euh enfin se développe ou en
tout cas faire des web web service ou
autre parce que je crois qu'il y a un
sujet sur la partie technique euh mais
euh on nous a dit quand même à la
direction des sport qu'il faudrait
améliorer ce ce ce ce chiffre là juste
pour que je comprenne bien euh en fait
quand vous dit 30000 personnes dont il
faut faire le contrôle
d'honorabilité pourquoi c'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui est-ce que c'est parce que
vous ne pouvez pas rentrer les 30000
nons ou est-ce que c'est parce que vous
avez rentré les 30000 NS et qu' a eu des
retours sur lequels on peut pas faire le
contrôle
d'honorabilité moi je pense que il y a
je vous dis il y a eu les deux il y a eu
le fait que pardon il y a eu des retours
donc des des contrôles qui ont pas pu
être réalisés parce que le logiciel
n'est pas au point ça c'est sûr mais on
a aussi des difficultés et il faut être
transparent je vous l'ai dit on est
transparent avec nos dirigeants
territoriaux nos dirigeants de ligue sur
lesquels on insiste on insiste on
insiste et on n' pas toujours les
remontés comme disait monsieur le député
tout à l'heure ben vous avez des
bénévoles qui sont sur le terrain on
leur dit maintenant il faut que tu
fasses que tu remplisses ce ce logiciel
que tu bon les gars il y a beaucoup de
il y a eu de la négligence mais il y a
quand même une grosse progression
puisque chaque année on progresse mais
on insiste on le rappelle dans toutes
nos réunions dans nos assemblées
générales on le rappelle que les
dirigeants les entraîneurs doivent
obligatoirement remplir ce questionnaire
voyez est-ce que l'intégralité de vos
bénévoles à la FFA sont licenciés dans
un
club comme le souhaite la ministre des
Sports pour permettre une tracabilité de
normalement tous nos bénévols sont
licenciés oui en ce que ce que nous
identifions hein vous dites normalement
est-ce que est possible de de le
vérifier ou pas ou est-ce que c'est un
une consigne écrite que vous transmettez
alors c'est ça pardon ça fait partie
justement de notre règlement intérieur
ça fait partie aussi de nos statuts tous
les membres d'un club doivent êt être
licencié à la Fédération Française
d'Athlétisme j'ai pas dit tous les
membres des clubs ils sont licenciés
mais tous les bénévolesoui les bénévoles
les bénévoles qui intervien bénévoles
qui encadr doivent être licenciés ça
fait partie des statuts la fédération
qui encadre ou qui
interviennne intervien qui soit juge
arbitre comment vous pouvez le vérifier
on le vérifie avec nos présidents de
ligue he on a effectivement on a
sanctionné voyez par exemple donc tous
les bénévoles de près ou de loin d'un
club quel qu'il soit au quatre coin de
France tous ces bénévoles sont licenciés
à la Fédération pas tous pas tous en
fait ceux qui sont entre j'entend bien
dans les clubs dans les clubs ils sont
licentiés voyez par exemple
on se comprend pas où voilà moi je pose
la question s' y a un
bénévole travaille travaille ou en tout
cas donne de son temps bénévolement
auprès d'un club quel qu'il soit est-ce
qu'il est licencié obligatoirement ou
pas j'ai pas dit un entraîneur un coach
sportif j'ai juste dit un
bénévole par exemple un bénévole c'est
un bénévole qui soit pur ou pas pur il
un bénévole non mais je un bénévole pur
oui oui pur voilà non mais pur ce que
veux dire pur c'estàd quelqu'un qui va
être par exemple un dimanche matin et
qui va attendre des gobelet de verre à
des coureurs qui a pas de voilà par
exemple par exemple voilà c'est c'est
là-dessus que je vous dis c'est le le le
bénévole volontaire qui n'est pas
impliqué toute l'année dans un club cela
effectivement quand on fait appel à une
organisation l'organisateur il réunit
son réseau de bénévoles de sa commune
ils sont pas tous licenciés mais pour
l'encadrement oui voilà l'encadrement du
club pour l'encadrement c'est
indispensable après le gars qui va
transporter par exemple des des javelot
ou des poids dans sa voiture pour aider
un président de club à aller sur de
compétition ou qui va attendre un vert
sur une course il est pas
obligatoirement
licencié peut-être qu'on pourrait se
poser la question et c'est une question
qui est posée par la ministre des Sports
Amélie oua cterin parce que par
justement si il prend la voiture le
dimanche matin il est bénévole il
accompagne certainement des mineurs s'il
prend la voiture et il pourrait être
licencié au sein de la fédération pour
ensuite avoir une traçabilité on va dire
mais positive j'entends bien au sein de
la du club donc de la Fédération vous
rendez compte que nous sommes favorables
bien sûr pour gagner des licenciés comme
nous avons comme la proposition alors je
déborde du cadre c'est pas le cadre des
déviances mais la proposition que nous
formulons depuis que je suis élu et où
on m'écoute mais j'ai l'impression qu'on
m'entend pas trop c'est que il y a 10
millions de runers en France de
personnes qui courent et et on a 300000
licenciés pourtant il font de
l'athlétisme et on les autorise à courir
avec des organisations privées qui sont
pas affilié à la Fédération alors nous
avons simplement dit aux différents
ministres que si simplement on leur
demandait de payer
1 € par an on avait plus besoin des
crédits du ministère 10 millions
d'euros si chaque Runner chaque
marathonien versait 1 € par an pour
pouvoir courir à la Fédération on a plus
besoin d'argent public mais
malheureusement voilà c'est et je vous
signale quand même que c'est ce qui se
passe pour le triathlon et pour le
cyclisme vous pouvez pas faire du
triathlon si vous êtes pas
licencié nous on va plus loin on on on
le oblige pas la licence on demande
simplement avoir un lien avec la
Fédération pour économiser l'argent
public ça aussi c'est des
questions et on serait certainement la
première fédération de France parce que
il y a pas 10 millions de footballeurs
hein et on a 10 millions de rurs donc
c'est une question qui nous interpelle
tous
notre collègue Claude guarouo oui
bonjour monsieur le Président alors
veuillez m'excuser de de mon retard mais
j'ai découvert il y a quoi 30 minutes au
salon des mères que il y avait
l'audition donc je suis arrivée très
très vite non voilà moi j'étais il y a
pas plus tard que 15 jours avec une très
très grosse association d'athlétisme
très grosse 500 170 licenciés et le
président me faisait par du fait qu'il
avait fait un signalement par rapport un
entraîneur qui avait eu des SMS un peu
douteux envers des jeunes filles en fait
les les jeunes filles quittaient le club
il s'est interrogé et il s'est rendu
compte que il est harcelé il a fait un
signalement la dragesse de d Villain
puisque je suis d Villain ensuite cet
entraîneur est parti dans un autre club
le club a appelé le président parce
qu'il avait bien eu fait euh qui avait
eu un souci donc il lui a dit voilà ce
qui s'est passé il l'a pas pris il est
il est allé dans un autre club du sud de
la France mais je pourrais vous
transmettre ses coordonnées ensuite et
puis finalement il est passé à l'acte et
aujourd'hui il est revenu dans son club
initial je crois que c'est am manth
amant man tes euh où son père est
d'ailleurs un entraîneur notoire et donc
en fait on se rend compte que malgré le
signalement à la dragesse en île Villen
il est passé à la trappe et aujourd'hui
ben il est revenu dans son club
d'origine donc moi je je je je voudrais
comprendre aussi comment parce que là le
le président du club qui est lui aussi
bénévole qui n'a pas forcément toute
connaissance juridique il a fait le
travail il a fait le signalement et tout
et puis on se rend compte que il a
continué à exercer en tant qu'
entraîneur rémunéré hein BE1 ou be2 dans
des clubs d'athelet en France et puis
qu'il a fini quand même par passer à
l'acte voilà donc je j'aimerais savoir
quelles sont les failles dans la
Fédération alors je suis vraiment désolé
hein parce que j'ai écouté quand même
votre audition euh en replay parce qu'on
arrive déjà à la voir mais qu quelles
sont les failles qui qui ne permettent
pas aujourd'hui de de finalement de
sanctionner mais professionnellement
parlant quelqu'un qui au préalable
c'était des SMS envers des gamines de 13
ans puis que après passer à l'acte moi
je vous m'apprenez quelque m'apprenez un
dossier est-ce qu'il a signalé la
Fédération bah il a signalé la tragesse
quand même non mais enfin la dragesse
c'est l'état et voilà donc voilà bi
franchement je vous le dis je connais
pas le dossier mais si ça nous est
signalé je l'ai dit tout à l'heure ça va
immédiatement en commission de
discipline et c'est traité dans les 10
semaines ça c'est sûr surtout c'est
c'est c'estes problèmes graves voyez
mais sil a signalé la dragess et que la
dragess n'a pas fait remonter c'est ça
c'est le problème des interlocuteur
alors juste moi je suis quand même très
interrogative euh
pas par rapport à vous spécifiquement
mais comment vous expliquez qu'un
président de club il fait le signalement
à la dragess c'est très bien mais
comment vous expliquez qu'il ne fasse
pas le remonter l'information à la
Fédération est-ce que quelque part
est-ce que lorsqu'il deviennent
président d'un club ou d'une ligue ou je
ne sais pas comment est-ce que il y a
pas une charte dans laquelle il signent
quelque chose pour dire ils ont
l'obligation de faire remonter à la
Fédération les fait qui leur
sont la charte existe quand il s
licencié alors soit il a coché sans lire
la charte c'est de l'ignorance
effectivement nous avons mis en place
alors depuis plusieurs années nous
sommes une des rares fédérations aussi à
avoir mis en place une formation de
dirigeants avec des diplômes de
dirigeants il y a trois degrés de
diplômes et chaque année on a des
dirigeants justement qui passent les
différents modules dont le premier
module est consacré à l'éthique avant
d'aller plus loin si ce dirigeant on
contrôlera vous nous ferez passer les
noms on va contrôler si ce dirigant
n'est pas diplômé qu'il a pris vous
savez souvent dans le bénévola il y a un
dirigeant qui démissionne parce que ben
il a plus le temps de s'occuper du club
c'est un are dirigeant notre un bénévole
qui prend la présidence du club sinon le
club va s'écrouler vous dites que c'est
un club important donc je pense qu'il a
été élu par une assemblée générale mais
si s'il a contacté la dragess et qu'il a
pas contacter au moins son président de
ligue c'est qu' il connaît pas le
fonctionnement et ça nous interpelle
effectivement comme ça vous Interpel à
vous effectivement il y a des failles
oui
oui je je vais vous répondre parce que
ce club je le connais depuis 20 ans le
dirigeant il est exceptionnel c'est
vraiment quelqu'un de remarquable en
fait il connaissait pas la procédure la
dragesse pour lui c'était déjà important
et donc enfin moi je suis je je partage
tout à fait ce que ce qu'a dit la
rapporteur et elle m'a enlevé les mots
c'est que je je pense qu'il manque
réellement d'information communication
importante il y en a plein bien
évidemment vous en donnez plein il y a
les juges Arbites il y a tout ça mais
surtout ce qui est violent c'est parce
que lui s'est retrouvé démuni mise à
pied immédiate il a tout fait bien et je
vous dire on a mangé ensemble il y a 15
jours il me dit bah tu sais tu m'avais
interpellé là-dessus bah voilà j'ai des
nouvell il est passé à l'acte et tout
donc je pense qu'il a été exemplaire
dans sa démarche sauf que il lui a
manqué alors il en a certainement parlé
au au président enfin je pense au
président de ligue de Bretagne au moins
pour qu'ils évitent de le recruter mais
sauf que je vous dis il a même
l'formation elle a circulé puisque il y
a un président de club qui l'a appelé et
et à qui il a dit benainant surtout pas
évite et il lui a expliqué donc il a il
y a un vrai sujet
sur enfin je pense qu'il faut vraiment
sécuriser parce que effectivement le
l'athlétisme c'est des c'est des
centaines de clubs c'est des centaines
de bénévoles des gens qui font du mieux
qu'il peuvent pour porter leur leur
association mais il y a vraiment un
manque de communication sur tout ce qui
est violence sexuelle sexiste mais même
raciste tout enfin on peut aller
beaucoup plus loin mais quand ça
s'attaque à des enfants enfin je veux
dire c'est quelque chose et et mais
c'est pas que pour vous hein c'est pour
quasiment toutes les fédérations pas
toutes parce qu'on en a trouvé une qui
était remarquable hein sur ça donc ça
existe mais je pense qu'il y a une vraie
faille sur un président qui est bénévole
qui donne énormément de son temps qui a
deux ou trois salariés c'est pas facile
avoir des
salariés dans le milieu associatif on le
sait bien et donc et puis qui se
retrouve coincé mais qui pense avoir
bien fait en fait en fait c'est ça et je
pense qu'il avait bien fait mais ou
alors c'est au niveau des dragesses
pourquoi il y a pas eu c'est pas allé
plus
loin juste peut-être pour nous préciser
les choses aujourd'hui en matière
d'obligation pour un président de club
ou un président de ligue euh est-ce que
vous vous avez parlé de la Charte mais
en fait est-ce qu'il y a une obligation
en tout cas une inscription quelque part
une forme de contrat qui est passé au
moment où on est élu président de club
ou de ligue sur les le minimum à faire
quand on a un cas de signalement ou une
affaire VSS racisme discrimination
comment ça se passe est-ce qu'on est-ce
que par exemple la fédération est très
précise sur le process à suivre pour les
présidents oui alors déjà par notre je
répète par notre charte et notre code
éthique qui est sur le site de la
fédération et par lequel ils doivent
passer avant de se licencier donc le
président de club est censé avoir lu
cette charte on a beaucoup communiquer
sur la charte éthique on va relancer
d'ailleurs une nouvelle campagne de
communication on on y fait référence
dans les formation on y fait
référence j'entends que ce soit pour le
licencié qui signe cette charte dans
laquelle il y a beaucoup d'information
mais spécifiquement pour les dirigeants
de club ou de
ligu oui mais même s'ils sont licencié
quand on est licencié on signe la charte
on arrive on signe la charte il faut
informer mais quand on est responsable
dirigeant d'un club ou d'une ligue on a
des responsabilités plus importantes
donc est-ce que selon vous alors s'il y
a pas de document qui est fait
aujourd'hui avec un un règlement précis
sur les obligations d'un dirigeant de
club ou de ligue est-ce que c'est pas
justement quelque chose sur lequel il
faut réfléchir pour que lorsqu'on
devient dirigeant d'un club et bien on
ait des obligations qui sont inscrites
sur ce qu'on a à faire en matière de
déclaration à la Fédération notamment
sur par exemple des cas de VSS alors il
y a il y a deux aspects si vous voulez
le premier déjà euh on a un système de
labelllisation des clubs on a des clubs
labelllisés d'autres qui le sont pas
pour être labelllisé le dirigeant doit
avoir le diplôme de dirigeant donc les
clubs
labélisés les les les dirigeants
obligatoirement ont passé le module de
formation le premier module de formation
sur l'éthique et sur leur droit et leurs
devoirs ça c'est alors je sais pas si ce
club est laéisé ou non
hein si labellisé c'est que ben ben le
président n'a pas suivi les
consignes
comment voilà donc normalement un club
labélisé doit son son son président doit
avoir un diplôme de dirigeant donc s'il
a passé le diplôme c'est qu'il est passé
par toutes les fourches donc il devrait
connaître les procédures voilà s'il est
labellisé il y a pas de problème pour
les clubs les nouveaux clubs vous savez
les petits clubs qui se créent en milieu
rural ou dans les quartiers où on a on
est est vraiment heureux d'avoir des
bénévoles qui lancent une activité ils
sont pas encore labilisés parce que B on
est content qu'il y a un bénévole qui
s'en occupe sinon il y a personne mais
on les incite justement à passer ces
formations mais on on tient compte ce
que vous avez dit Madame la rapporteur
et on va faire en sorte maintenant
d'appuyer encore plus sur les démarches
à entreprendre lorsqu'il y a un cas à
signaler
voyez et on fonctionne aussi en
circulaire avec nos nos clubs donc on
envoie des circulaires les inform
de choses très
administratives et il y a à peine un
mois nous avons envoyé des éléments sur
notamment l'adresse mail signal donc et
on travaille non la nôtre la nôre c'est
pour ça que la question elle peut aussi
se poser
et j'ai parlé de la refondte du site
internet de la Fédération toutes les
fédérations on a ces problématiques là n
avec la densité d'événements qu'on peut
avoir ou de discipline on retrouve pas
forcément les choses rapidement donc là
il y a tout un travail qui va se
réaliser qui est en train de se réaliser
avec l'ensemble des acteurs parce que on
discute avec l'ensemble des acteurs et
puis avec un outil ce qu'on appelle CRM
pour mieux parler mieux cibler les les
personnes qu'on parle pas de la même
façon un licencié qui fait de la course
à pied qu'un bénévole ou qu' un
président de club donc toute cette
communication sera meilleure
forcément dès la rentrée
merci
alors pour partager un peu vos propos
sur les associations qui organisent des
cours sur route ou qui en fait elles
sont pas effectivement affiliées à la
Fédération d'athelé et ça c'est un sujet
où sur lequel il faudra qu'on regarde de
près parce que elle elles œuvrent
complètement moi j'en ai beaucoup on
voit bien parce que ça coûte moins cher
parce que si parce que ça parce que
derrière c'est souvent des des raisons
financières et je partage votre remarque
là-dessus il faut qu'on soit vigilant
parce que là ça sort de tout euh tout
contrôle et il y en a de plus en plus
écoutez je vous remercie madame la
députée si vous pouvez appuyer parce que
je vous dis depuis 2017 c'est des
propositions que je formule
régulièrement alors je je reprends he
l'histoire l'histoire parce que ça va
peut-être vous aider l'histoire c'est
que lorsque les courses sur route
maintenant c'est les Trailles la
montagne enfin les courses nature
lorsque c'est arrivé dans le paysage de
l'athlétisme les les dirigeants des
années 70 pensaient que c'était des
concurrents et n'ont pas voulu
s'intéresser il y a une faute de la
Fédération au départ c'estàd on les a
laissé se développer sauf que ce qui
était quelque chose de convivial au
début sont devenus de grosses affaires
commerciales et où il y a beaucoup
d'argent qui circule et cet argent qui
circule bien il est pas dans le
mouvement sportif il pourrait permettre
à des clubs de créer des emplois voyez
voilà donc ça veut dire qu'aujourd'hui
il faut se pencher sur qui a le droit et
puis il y a pas de prévention médicale
il y a pas de prévention médicale on a
relevé des cas je peux vous le dire où
soit-disant on doit fournir un
certificat médical mais ce sont des
certificats médicaux de complaisance ou
des photocopies de certificats médicaux
on a relev voyez alors que dans un club
il y a quand même une garantie au moins
d'avoir une prévention médicale voilà
donc c'est extrêmement important et je
vous dis ça ferait faire des économies à
l'état
estimez-vous que votre comité d'éthique
fonctionne de manière satisfaisante et
suffisamment indépendant a-t-il connu
des démissions et pour quelle raison
oui euh alors qui qui première question
est-ce qu'il fonctionne normalement et
suffisamment je dis oui pour vous dire
je je ris parce que j'ai pratiquement le
président deux fois par semaine au
téléphone qui m'interpelle par rapport à
des cas d'alertes qu'il a eu sur
différents dossiers en me disant voilà
j'étais alerté sur ce dossier c'est pas
des dossiers lourds hein mais euh vous
savez des des des des prises de de
parole
entre un athlète et un arbitre enfin des
choses comme ça oui il fonctionne et il
est composé de personnes euh qui qui
prennent ce travail à cœur alors il y a
eu des démissions comme je vous l'ai dit
au début euh des personnes qu'on aurait
aimé intégrer mais qui ne s'entendaient
pas avec le président actuel donc des
problèmes de relation personnelles et de
points de vue différents et je regrette
que ces personnes n démissionné bien sûr
mais bon on les a on les a pas mis si
sont partis de leur propre grs voilà et
sur quel sujet il n'y avait pas de
terrain
d'ententeque de ne pas pouvoir
intervenir sur des
sanctions alors que le comité d'éthique
n'a pas un pouvoir de sanction
c'estàdire il y avait eu eu deux ou
trois affaires sur lesquelles ces
personneslà estimaient qu'elle devait
que le le la cellule qu'elle constitué
devait prendre des sanctions à la place
de la commission de discipline or le
comité d'éthique n'est là que pour des
recommandations et pas des sanctions
voilà c'est pour cette raison qu'il y a
eu des
divergences
ok sur ce sur ce comité d'éthique vous
nous aveit dit euh parce que la question
exacte c'était est-ce qu'il fonctionne
de manière satisfaisante euh ça veut
dire que pour vous les avis qui sont
rendus aujourd'hui correspondent à
l'attente que vous en
aviez
ok donc sur ce comité d'éthique juste
combien de démissions il y a eu jusqu'à
présent de mémoire 2 il me semble oui
c'est ça de de qui date depuis 2018 ou
non20 de depuis 2018 ou
2019 est-ce que euh la composition de ce
comité d'éthique est paritaire
aujourd'hui le comité d'éthique a été
lorsqu'il a été créé en 2013 donc par
mon prédécesseur il a nommé euh un
président hein de comité qui ensuite a
formé sa commission mais le comité n'est
pas paritaire pour l'instant et on
prévoit justement dans le prochain
mandat de le rendre
paritaire pas paritaire ça veut dire
combien d'hommes et combien de
femmes
as les services là aussi voilà oui
actuellement il y a huit hommes et
quatre femmes
oui et il participe également les
services de femmes qui sont deux femmes
d'ailleurs ok
euh sur les dernières démissions de ce
comité d'éthique est-ce que c'était Cece
que vous nous avez indiqué que c'était
sur le fait de pouvoir prononcer des
sanctions ou pas est-ce que c'était
vraiment que ça le sujet ou est-ce
que il y avait d'autres choses justement
qui ont provoqué cette
démission à ma connaissance les deux
personnes qui ont démissionné c'était
uniquement parce qu'elles étaient pas en
accord sur les procédure juridiqu de la
Fédération qu'on deit mettre en place je
résume hein elle estimer que il y avait
de un ou deux cas sur lesquels c'était
le comité d'éthique qui devait prononcer
les sanctions or nous nous avons estimé
c'est pas estimé c'est la réglementation
qu'il y avait une commission de
discipline et le comité d'éthique se
saisit et envoie la commission de
discipline alors qu'elle voulait qu'on
sanctionne tout de suite c'est tout et
donc elles étaient pas d'accord il y a
eu des échanges de mail et puis elles
ont démissionné ce que je regrette
d'ailleurs
ell ne connaissait pas le fonctionnement
disons administratif de la fédération et
juridique vous dites qu'il y a quatre
femmes dans ce comité d'éthique oui
oui quatre femmes dont deux des services
oui non qu plus
deoui les deux démissions ce sont des
femmes
donc il n'y a plus de femmes dans ce
comité d'éthique au fmes c'était ça on
était là les démissions avent les
démissions se sont produit dans le
mandat
2017-2020 là c'est a un nouveau mandat
avec une nouvelle composition du comité
d'éthiqueion ah non ma connaissance non
la dernière c'est 201 la dernière c'est
2018 ou 2019 2020 2020 2020 je sais pas
c'est ou 2020 il y a eu deux démissions
à ma connaissance he
2020 chers collègues pas de
question très bien
ah Monsieur Gérou il faut libérer le
micro si s'il vous plaît
euh donc moi juste parce que je suis
arrivé un peu plus tard euh moi j'ai vu
votre
intervention vis-à-vis des collègues je
trouve que leur travail est remarquable
et que nous avons tous été très affecté
des premières auditions que nous avons
fait sur les deux athlètes d'athlétisme
où on considère qu'il y a eu quand même
des manquements et j'espère que lors de
ces à la fin de ces auditions ENF en
tout cas le fait de qu'une victime
devienne doublement victime et qu'on
invite à retourner chez elle je
considère que c'est un manquement et que
j'espère que à la suite de ces auditions
et qu'on puisse tous prendre conscience
que on n'est pas en état de juger si la
personne un jour c'est oui un jour c'est
non non quand il y a quand la personne
considère qu'elle a été abusée et bien
c'est un signalement immédiat point
c'est tout c'est à la justice après de
regarder mais c'est pas même un comité
d'ctique ou à des personnes qui sont pas
forcément juridiquement à la hauteur
même nous tous he enfin en tout cas mais
mais on a été très affecté de de cette
première audition en tout cas moi titre
personnel je l'ai été et je comprends
tout à fait la démarche d'aller plus
loin pour essayer justement que à
l'avenir vous savez moi j'ai j'ai
rencontré Catherine Moyon de bec et
quand j'ai écouté ces deux athlètes j'ai
revécu ce qu'elle avait vécu avec ses
lanceurs peut-être 20 ans après de
mémoire 94 je crois quelque chose comme
ça peut-être moins si ça doit être ça 30
ans même en tout cas c'était il y a
longtemps et avec ce sentiment qu'on
avait pas suffisamment progressé donc
voilà pourquoi on est peut-être un peu
tenace mais que derrière c'est de
l'humain c'est des femmes et que tout le
monde doit pouvoir s'épanouir tant
sportivement parlant mais
surtout à titre à titre personnel donc
voilà moi je je en tout cas je suis en
grand soutien avec mes collègues qui
vousont peut-être un peu titillé mais
ils ont eu raison parce que le fond
hyper important et je tenais à le
dire que vous évoquez Catherine
je vais vous dire que nous aussi on
avait alors c'est les années
90 j'étais j'étais tout juste licencié à
la Fédération j'erc pas de
responsabilité mais j'avais eu
connaissance de cette affaire et il y a
un an à peu près on s'est retrouvé au
Comité olympique sur une soirée de
remise des
récompenses quand j'ai vu qu'elle était
là parce que elle a été citée je me suis
approché d'elle elle a refusé de me ser
Z ça vous marque quand même hein parce
que j'étais le président de la
fédération à l'époque je je voulais
m'ententenir avec elle donc je l'ai fait
approcher pour qu'on se rencontre elle
est venue à la Fédération on a fait
d'ailleurs un numéro spécial sur son cas
que je sais pas si vous l'avez vu ce
numéro mais je peux vous le remettre je
l' encore un exemplaire là elle est en
première de page et je peux vous dire
que depuis quand on se croise elle me
remercie pour ce que la Fédération a
fait justement avec avec ce numéro
spécial que nous avons remis à la
Commission qui a été distribué à tous
les licenciés et dans lequel d'ailleurs
il y a ouu aussi hein voilà où elles ont
eu la parole elles ont pris la parole et
il y a 15 pages sur ce caslà donc moi
comme vous j'ai été affecté bien sûr par
ce qui s'est passé il y a quelques
années et par ce qui se passe maintenant
c'est vrai que dans les ressentis et
j'ai écouté j'ai réécouté l'interview de
Emma et de CLA c'est vrai que dans les
ressentis on sent que il y a toujours ce
reproche qui est fait à la Fédération la
fédération ne fait rien ne fait rien
mais je peux vous garantir c'est ce qui
a peut-être provoqué un petit peu ce
dialogue d'incompréhension à la première
édition d'ailleurs les dossiers sont là
les voilà les les dossiers les dossiers
Palou et oudou c'est plus de 200 pages
ils ont été traités par la Fédération
ils ont été traités dans un cadre
juridique propre à la Fédération pour ça
que je disais que chaque fédération a
son cadre juridique mais on peut pas
dire que on a laissé tomber l'affaire
voilà on a traité les cas voilà on a
traité les cas et les deux derniers cas
dont qui ont qui ont fait l'objet un peu
de notre différents ont abouti les deux
derniers cas ont abouti à des non lieux
par la police et la justice de notre
pays que peut-on faire de plus si ce
n'est d'avoir toujours le contact avec
elles de les accompagner mais on ne à
partir de moment où il y a les enquêtes
de police qui n'ont pas condamné les
présumés coupables on n'est pas des
juges voilà c'est tout c'est c'est le le
c'est pour ça qu'il y a eu peut-être
dans cette première audition des
incompréhensions des deux côtés c'est
tout mais je vais vous le remettre vous
verrez euh et j'ai le même sentiment que
vous d'ailleurs quand on se rencontre
actuellement les rapports ne sont plus
les mêmes
ouais puisque vous évoquez euh ces deux
cas euh moi je vais me permettre de
revenir quand même là-dessus parce que
vous aujourd'hui on est dans le cadre de
cette 2e audition de la Fédération
d'athlétisme mais vous vous vous avez dû
aussi constater dans leur audition que
c'est normal d'être interrogatif quand
on a un signalement on a des athlète en
détresse euh et que l'article 40 ne se
fait que plusieurs mois après le
signalement alors même que normalement
il est censé être fait immédiatement là
c'est pas le cas dans ce dossier en
l'occurrence et je dis pas c'est la
fédération de l'athlétisme ou pas parce
qu'en l'occurrence c'est l'INSEP qui a
fait l'article 40 donc on voit bien
quand même qu'il y a il y a eu quelque
part et j'entends que la Fédération
aujourd'hui dise mais nous on a traité
on a fait ce qu'il fallait mais il y a
eu un classement il y a eu un non lieu
sauf que et vous l'avez rappelé à juste
titre que le pouvoir des fédérations
c'est 10 semaines d'instruction pour une
mesure disciplinaire la justice ça peut
être beaucoup plus long et en
l'occurrence parfois et bien il peut
être nécessaire d'avoir une sanction
disciplinaire en amont de la sanction de
justice et même souvent le cas quand ça
se produit pour justement mettre à
l'abri la victime ou d'autres
potentielles Vic d'ailleurs et là on a
un peu le sentiment quand même et c'est
c'est là aussi où c'est intéressant
d'auditionner tous les acteurs de cette
affaire c'est que on voit bien que
quelque part peut-être le fait qu'il y
ait eu deux entités différentes sur ce
dossier et bien que ça a pris plusieurs
mois pour avoir un article 40 mais on a
eu la même chose dans la Fédération de
football où il a fallu un an pour se
rendre compte que le l'article 40
n'avait pas été fait donc vous voyez
bien c'est pas spécifique à la
Fédération de l'athlétisme mais il y a
bien quand même des fonctionnement qui
explique ou pas d'ailleurs le fait
qu'aujourd'hui on se retrouve avec des
victimeses qui ont eu le sentiment
peut-être à tort ou à raison mais nous
on n'est pas là pour juger de leur
sentiments à elles qu'elles n'ont pas
été entendu qu'elles n'ont pas été cru
qu'elles n'ont pas été écouté et
qu'elles ont le sentiment oui que leurs
affaires n'ont pas été traité comme
elles auraient dû l'être et au niveau
qu'elles auraient mérité et en fait je
pense que la difficulté elle est
vraiment là ma cgue l'a rappelé les
premières auditions qu'on a faites ont
été extrêmement difficiles pour tous les
membres de cette commission d'entendre
ces victimes qui parfois ont mis des
années avant de pouvoir s'exprimer sur
leur sur leurs affaires et donc c'est
vrai qu'avoir en face des dirigeants
dont certains ont pris la mesure des
choses mais pour d'autres qui n'en ont
pas du tout conscience et bien nous
notre objectif à nous c'est pas de
pointer du doigt telle ou telle personne
mais c'est de dire à un moment il y a
des failles comment on fait pour y
remédier et je pense que tout l'objectif
de cette commission il est
là juste si je peux je peux me permettre
il a sans d' une incompréhension dans
notre première
audition la Fédération aujourd'hui avait
le sentiment que on avait rien fait pour
ces deux athlètes là donc distinguer
finalement toute la la la
la la partie juridique administrative
qui nous semblait être fait dans les
dans les bonnes conditions dans les
règles de l'art en dehors de
effectivement ce cet article 40 on a
appris des choses he que le président
pouvait aussi déclencher un article 40
donc il y avait eu un décalage de
perception on a reg regardé encore et
évidemment que euh on est touché quand
on voit ces deux
athlètes qui s'expriment devant la
commission mes collaborateurs qui ont
réalisé ces interviews étaient touchés
eux-mêmes 20 ans après ils étaient même
pas nés pour pour pour certains donc
pour nous c'est aussi de la prévention
on n' pas fait de la communication même
si c'est important euh pour pouvoir
faire de de la prévention donc il y a eu
un décalage de perception entre encore
une fois la partie juridique euh froide
finalement la relation avec l'athlète et
à côté de ça parce que quand Emma dit
j'ai quelqu'un sur le terrain qui
s'appelle Guillaume qui qui qui qui
récolte la parole il travaille à la
fédération en fait c'est un cadre
technique mais il est pas identifié
comme ça donc donc euh peut-être
qu'effectivement dans notre
communication euh euh définir les
personnes ressources pour se rendre
compte que la Fédération fait des choses
et on fait des choses et on pourra
toujours mieux faire c'est sûr donc le
premier enseignement c'est que ensuite
qu'est-ce qu'on fait pour les
accompagner psychologiquement c'est pas
l'objet de la
Fédération par contre on peut
éventuellement
trouver à travers le
médical trouver des des des des des
comment dire des systèmes qui puissent
parce que tous les athlètes ne veulent
pas non plus s'exprimer après une fois
que euh elle elle est venue enfin
elleelle elle a subi finalement la
commission de discipline après je vrais
juste finir moi j'ai été heurté aussi
puisque euh je suis une femme je je suis
ancien athlète membre d'un club je peux
pas je dirige cette fédération je peux
pas entendre euh que c'est l'omerta à la
Fédération c'est c'est c'était c'est et
donc il y avit une incompréhension euh
aussi euh dans la façon dont on on s'est
nous exprimer et comment on a compris
aussi euh peut-être les premiers mots
euh lorsque vous nous avez interrogé
mais euh on est là pour faire avancer le
débat alors peut-être juste pour
préciser aussi les choses
euh c'est c'est le directeur de l'insab
qui a dit que la Fédération avait mis du
temps à réagir c'est pas nous c'est pas
nous qui l'avons inventé euh au moment
de cette première audition ce que je
veux dire par là c'est que peut-être que
d'ailleurs vous prendrez un temps pour
échanger entre l'INSP et et votre
fédération pour faire le un retour
d'expérience sur malheureusement cette
affaire et et les difficultés et les
dysfonctionnements qui ont pu auxquels
ça a pu donner lieu mais en l'occurrence
sur cette affaire précisément c'est bien
monsieur Canu qui nous a indiqué la
Fédération d'athlétisme a mis du temps à
réagir et donc c'est pour ça qu'on avait
posé la question y compris sur l'article
40 pour savoir qui l'avait fait parce
que quand on nous dit qu'on est averti
en février et qu'on fait un article 40
le 1er septembre
bien ça
interroge merci à vous merci pour votre
présence renouvelée à cette commission
d'enquête bonne soirée
merci